All
right.
Well good.
Yes.
Back from the mother fucking jungle.
Justin rand.
Savan pygmies hanging out,
having a good time.
It's not brother.
Alright man,
I'm excited to be here and excited to have you.
I've been paying attention to your crazy travels and your journeys and you
brought some pictures and videos for us today to,
and how long have you been back for?
I've been back since,
uh,
late October.
And you were,
you were here for you.
We're here for a little while and the last time you were supposed to be here you
were real sick.
And I gotta be honest with you.
We weren't too excited about a dude fresh back from Africa common and with some
sort of funky jungle virus.
Yeah.
Well I'm glad I didn't come in.
What did you have?
Did you have anything crazy?
What had bronchitis and then,
um,
but before that had Shigella,
which is a intestinal bacteria I don't like,
is that he get that,
uh,
it's a waterborne disease.
Waterborne.
So you turn the corner up there.
Yeah,
there was just times that I couldn't help it,
but uh,
yeah.
Or it could be from food or a fly landing on your food while it's been cooked or
oh,
there's many different ways that you can get it.
Whoa.
So you either leave live your life like the boy in the plastic bubble.
Remember that John Travolta movie?
I think that's the only way.
You can't get sick.
How many times you've gotten sick over there.
Uh,
all throughout.
All throughout.
You're always sick.
Yeah.
I had this guy on the Scifi show that I did who told me that everyone who lives
in South American or,
um,
jungle climate,
everyone has parasites.
Oh yeah.
They just live with them.
Yeah.
I had them too.
Uh,
I got,
I had Amoebas,
some kind of parasite and my stomach also.
I'm actually still a bruise from here cause I've got seven vials of blood drawn
to see what kind of parasites are still in me still recently.
Yeah.
That's just a few days old.
So it's,
it's been a battle since coming back.
Um,
but I think I'm getting,
I'm on the track to get my health back together.
So crazy place to,
to live,
to spend your time.
It's a,
it's a very strange thing.
This,
uh,
the environment where you have like all these crazy tropical diseases.
Is it the heat and the moisture and all of the above and,
yeah,
I think it's just the entire environment.
It's a,
it's just brutal because right when I got there I got malaria and so that was
pretty bad.
Um,
so the mosquitoes,
the bugs,
the parasites,
everything can come mess with Ya.
Um,
yeah.
So the,
the water,
the climate,
the bad living conditions.
So I mean not having uh,
a nice bed and not having a good to sleep and um,
all those can contribute to what's a sickness.
Malaria is no joke.
Huh?
What was that like?
Oh man,
that was brutal.
That was uh,
one of the toughest times of my life.
But um,
I counted it as,
I dunno,
it was actually a good experience for me in the end because I got to,
to sharing the suffering that they're going through.
Cause cause they don't even have all the antibiotics and are all the medicine to
pump your body with to get healed from it.
So I had to be evolved out of the Congo and until you've gone to,
I was misdiagnosed for times.
So they drew my blood,
they did two quick test for malaria and they said it was negative.
Then they drew my blood,
said it was negative,
but a,
I got real sick,
real sick,
like six days.
I couldn't eat six days,
I couldn't urinate.
Um,
I think I lost 34 pounds.
and then whenever I finally did urinate and Uganda is after I got the right
medicine and they saw,
they took my blood out,
saw that had over 70,
70% of my bloodstream was parasites.
Why us?
70% of my,
my blood was,
was full of parasites.
They would hide in the liver and then they would distribute through your blood.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
Like you're invaded.
Yeah,
absolutely.
70% of your blood was parasites.
That,
am I getting that wrong?
Or 70% was infected with parasites set.
They said 70% of my bloodstream.
So they said between 60 and 70%.
So I was on the third tier,
like there's level one,
two and three and four and four.
I was right at right at four,
which was a coma.
So,
um,
when you get the,
for you,
you're in a coma and you,
it's,
it's pretty bad.
A lot of people die.
Well,
lucky or a strapping healthy young buck of a man that you got through that,
huh?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Man.
It was,
it was really good.
Like,
um,
I mean,
the pilot that flew me out,
it was actually on Thanksgiving of 2013 and he flew me out,
uh,
just me and him on the plane and he found out that they're misdiagnosing me,
that,
that my,
my buddy there was like,
the doctors don't know what's going on with him.
He's going to die if we don't get them out of here to a good hospital.
So they took me out of the jungle,
flew me to Uganda,
and when I landed and the ambulance came and picked me up because my vomit had
turned to blood and bile.
So it was literally,
I could smell,
you know,
like in the fight game,
you can smell the blood.
So a,
I could smell the iron,
I think in my blood.
And it was really,
it was literally Christmas colors,
red and green.
And it was brutal for two weeks after my esophagus was raw.
And so I could barely,
barely eaten much.
I mean,
I'd really have to chew it down a lot or it has to just drink a lot.
Um,
and so yeah,
replenishing my body after that was a whole,
I mean,
I think it's still happening,
but,
uh,
it was at least a month long process to,
to start putting weight back on.
See,
it's still happening from over a year ago.
Your body's still replenishing well from that and from some of the parasites and
everything else.
So yeah.
But the malaria,
I guess there's mixed reviews,
but a lot of times they say that the malaria never literally leaves your body
100%.
So it's,
it's it dormant in your
liver and then it can come back up whenever stress and other things happen.
So,
um,
wow.
So we're getting that tested.
That's one of the things we're testing for me so we can come back up.
Like say if you get run down,
like maybe if you get the flu or something like that,
malaria might go,
yeah,
that'd be brutal.
Cause my,
my fever got to like almost one oh five it was like one oh four one oh 4.5 or
1.41617 or something like that.
Like one 10 they were saying it was getting high enough to where like they
really had to watch me because of a cause.
It can do stuff to your brain,
your heart,
your brain gets too hot.
Right.
Parasites are terrifying,
man.
Don't ever watch that show you ever seen that show the enemy within,
what's it called?
The enemy within you are enemy inside you.
It's all about people who do what you do.
Go,
go to some place and get some crazy parasite.
And then they have like some softball size ball of worms living in your brain,
you know?
And they're like,
oh I have headaches.
I started seeing Jesus and the angels floating around me.
I couldn't figure out what it was.
And then I went to the doctor and they found this mass inside my brain.
And
I probably won't watch that.
Joan,
will you,
you'd live it.
I mean,
you don't have to watch it.
You live it.
We've got plenty of coconut water for you,
my friend.
If she wants them,
we got to see two.
Oh,
you ever have that shit?
No.
C Two o is the bomb.
Diggity get the man of Qantas.
E Two o.
All right,
thank you.
[inaudible] from Thailand.
They're,
they're,
yeah,
they're coconut waters.
Like it's really sweet.
It's weird.
It's a short tree.
It's only like five feet tall and a,
you know,
you think of like the big tall,
like palm trees.
It's being coconut trees,
but the tie trees or short and uh,
it's like a much sweeter.
You drink it,
you would swear that they have some sort of sugar in it,
but it's not,
it's totally natural to thank you.
It's delicious stuff.
Um,
but,
uh,
those parasites,
the thing about parasites is that it's really hard to root them out of your
system.
And some of them like trick a Gnosis I've found out recently,
my friend got trick and analysis and uh,
they said he's got essentially for life,
like they give them pills.
It flushed like the active parasites out of his system.
But like say tricking houses comes from an animal eating an animal with chicken
analysis.
So if somebody cannibalized him,
they would get trick analysis.
Wow.
Yeah.
To this day.
And he's walking around like a normal person,
but he's got trick analysis in his system essentially forever.
So that's like kind of how malaria is.
We,
I guess so like that's what,
that's what we're looking at.
By eight you I'd get malaria.
I hope not.
If you ain't my liver,
liver,
dude,
I'll tell you right now,
pretty confident.
Unless we're in some Donner parties type situation and you die first man,
it's,
it's nuts.
The,
the suffering that they're going through though with malaria is because they
don't have mosquito nets and all that other stuff.
So I was kind of a,
not cautious enough and the one thing I didn't want to do is take,
take uh,
uh,
malaria pill that would prevent malaria.
Um,
what's it called?
A prophylaxis or something like that,
something like that.
Um,
and so I didn't want to take that because a doctor here state
side said that if I took some of them,
they really intense,
um,
they can really hurt your body.
They also said that,
uh,
even mentally,
um,
taking them for a full year,
they could give you night terrors and terrible dreams,
but then also like people have a moments of psychosis from deacon on and stuff.
So I was like,
well,
I don't want to be dealing with that.
And if the guys in Congo said,
Oh yeah,
once you get malaria,
once,
um,
normally doesn't come back very bad.
And so all we have to do is,
oh,
we have to do it the next time.
The next time is much lower and much lower,
much lower.
And it's much more,
uh,
I don't know.
You can control it easier.
And so the thing that was the struggle with me,
it was that they misdiagnosed at four different times and we took it to two
different labs.
Um,
and they just didn't have the,
I guess the right tools and technology to really see that because whenever I got
there were,
were flying and I'm hugging a bucket and they put me,
whenever they were putting me into the ambulance,
I remember my vision was tunneling and,
and all in front of me was completely,
uh,
I mean it's just blur.
It's just a blur.
And then,
um,
and when you say tattling,
like could you actually see like the walls closing in?
Well,
not at first.
It was like I woke up one day and it was like all of a sudden my peripheral
vision was kind of blurry and that messed with me.
I was like,
what's going on?
Then all of a sudden started getting darker and so it didn't like start closing,
like if you're getting choked or something,
they didn't do that,
but it kind of stopped.
And I think it just prevented my peripheral vision from,
from really functioning or working.
Um,
and then the thing that sucks is,
is you get these crazy back and forth between shivering uncontrollably,
uncontrollably,
and your teeth chattering to then you all of a sudden just like on a diamond
switches and all of a sudden you're incredibly hot sweating and you're throwing
everything off and you're grabbing a fan and it just goes back and forth.
It goes back and forth for maybe 30 minutes or something.
You're,
you're terribly cold then for 30 minutes here.
Terribly hot and incredibly thirsty,
but then you drink something,
you vomited up.
Um,
and so they were trying to force me to eat cause they're like,
you don't have malaria.
You got to eat and everything I would eat,
I just vomit.
So don't have malaria.
You got to eat.
Yeah,
I had a,
I had,
I had one doctor there that,
uh,
they,
they couldn't agree with each other because they didn't know what was going on
with me.
So the up and coming doctor and one of the young nurses said this guy has got
malaria 100%,
but the older ones were just going off of the results.
And they're like,
no,
look,
you're going to see the first test,
second test or test or fourth test that says he doesn't have malaria.
And so there was some,
a humanitarian organization there and they had gotten this crazy,
I dunno,
virus or flu kind of thing.
And uh,
there'd be sick for three or four days and then they get better,
but it went through all of them.
And so they thought that I had gotten that.
So they said just let them ride it out and he'll get better.
Um,
and then kind of the,
the head kind of doctor that was overseeing it came and I was in my room but she
wouldn't even enter into the room cause um,
she was looking at me through the,
through the screen door saying I'm not coming in there.
I'm not risking me getting sick with that.
But malaria,
you can't pass on like that.
It's gotta be from a mosquito.
Do you know that malaria has killed half of all the people that have ever died?
I had no clue.
No.
It's the nuttiest statistic I've ever heard in my life.
I had to re re research it and look it up and find corroborating sources.
Yeah,
it's killed.
Half of all the people that have ever died ever died from malaria.
I think there's a guy named that's nuts.
That's fucking nuts.
That's crazy.
But listening to your story,
it's not surprising.
No,
not at all.
Um,
yeah,
it's brutal.
I think even if you go back and look at Congolese history,
um,
James Jamison I think is his name,
but he's one of the Jamison guys that founded the whiskey in Ireland.
He went,
and this is the story,
I think it's been conflicting,
but it's been confirmed by some,
some sources there that were with them traveling.
And he went to some of the cannibalistic like villages there in Congo back in
the day and the 18 hundreds.
And um,
he would actually,
that's crazy.
But he would buy some of the young kids and he would feed them to the cannibals
and he would,
he would do like art and stuff like that.
Um,
but yeah,
that's what they said about the Jamison guy.
The whiskey.
He would buy young kids from who from like slave villages and stuff like that.
But that's,
that's a big past in Congo.
Is that a tribes of enslaved other tribes and things like that?
Yeah.
So they would buy,
you can buy people there.
That's,
that's what happened whenever we brought a pygmy over to,
to the United States,
put them in the New York Zoo.
Um,
he lived in the monkey house for a couple of years and uh,
but you can just brought by,
yeah,
the Bronx Zoo and then also the Saint Louis world's fair.
And he toured around with them for a little bit,
got depressed,
got a gun and shot himself.
So she got off the security guard I think.
But um,
but with the Jamison Guy,
he,
he died and in Congo or Uganda from,
from malaria.
Well,
and that's been confirmed that he actually did that.
They actually bought people and fed little kids to these cannibals.
Well,
it looks like it because I think it was Stanley,
I forget Stanley's first name.
I think he was the one that confirmed it.
Like they had a,
they would go in and they would have to have protection.
So they would get some of the,
the warrior tribes there to protect themselves and then they would,
uh,
yeah,
in his downtime,
that's,
that's he was an artist or something that would paint pictures and stuff like
that.
So we put up pictures of suffering and then I'm pretty sure it happened at least
once I,
I mean maybe that's something that the listeners can go,
you'll look up or Google,
but I'm pretty sure it's a,
it's confirmed.
So are they relate,
I mean,
did the art,
was it related to the children being eaten?
Like draw art about that?
Yeah,
I think,
I think there's one confirmed story,
so I don't know that he did at a time,
but I know he did it once,
which is awful.
Terrible.
You know,
it's crazy.
Wow.
You know,
that's the weirdest thing about people's,
how,
how much they vary and how adaptable people are.
You know,
the people,
when they are involved,
when they're in,
in an environment where horrible things are going on,
they do horrible things.
Like people who've gone to war and if talked about horrific things that they've
witnessed and how it became normal and maybe it became a part of them and they,
they get contributed and they became a part of like these horrific war crimes,
like like riots.
Perfect example.
When people riot [inaudible] you take a person who would never throw a Molotov
cocktail or break a window or or stomp a cop to death or whatever,
but you get them involved in a group of 10,000 people that are doing the same
thing and it's almost like it's in the air.
It's like,
it's like people get infected by whatever's around them.
They sorta imitate their atmosphere and Congo and Uganda,
us all at once,
but they have something called mob justice.
And so that's a crazy thing,
kind of like with riots where if something happens,
someone just has to accuse somebody and then everyone comes in and in some cases
it's okay because if a thief is there and the Yelfie if then the whole community
surrounds a thief.
But the,
the,
the danger happens whenever someone wants to take justice into their own hands
in a sef,
turning that fif over to the authorities.
What they do is they beat him and kill him.
So me and my buddy Benjamin,
he's my translator.
We're walking down a center street of uh,
like basically main street,
one of these,
these big towns called Buena.
And in Booney they'd have a big,
uh,
past for lots of different struggles.
And even like,
I think a smaller kind of genocides,
well,
I say smaller,
but I think 50,000 people were killed there just in that one town,
50,000 people killed by different rebel groups,
machetes,
all this different stuff.
Um,
but we were walking down the street and someone yelled,
thief and nobody even confirmed it.
They grabbed the guy,
started beating him and then whenever we got up there,
bins grabbed me.
Say,
you don't want to be around this cause I'm,
I'm the only outsider there.
And so,
but at first my instant was like an instinct.
I didn't know that they were saying thief,
thief.
My instinct was like,
there's 30 guys pounded on this guy.
Like someone's got to give this guy some rooms,
give them some space.
He's grabbing my shirt,
pulling me.
And uh,
and so anyways,
whenever we went back and saw him,
his body was just twisted up and he's bent up in a,
in basically a ditch and then yeah,
they just beat him to death.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that for witchcraft too,
right?
They,
they accuse people of being witches and burn them alive.
That's a big problem with the orphans in,
in the Congo is that if they get accused of witchcraft,
they just excommunicate them from their family.
She so nice.
Yeah.
Well,
education man.
Right?
It's like these people have these ancient ideas that are based on just one
person who's ignorant telling another person is ignorant and becomes doctrine
and they just pass it down through generation and generation and they really
believe in witchcraft.
They have a real issue with albinos too.
They think that Albinos like that they're cursed or something like that or,
yeah.
Kirsten.
Then if you can kill,
Cook and eat an albino guy,
uh,
this is in Tanzania,
then I know that I can confirm this,
that,
um,
they'll,
if they can consume the flesh of an Albino,
then it can cure them of HIV,
tuberculosis.
Uh,
I dunno,
some other sicknesses to fuck.
That's crazy.
And that's,
that's with the pygmies.
While were there celebrating our first water,
well that we accomplished there.
Um,
some of the government officials came and said that this is the first ever,
uh,
clean water source among the pygmy people,
the more booties pygmies in,
in eastern Congo because the pygmies in or in many different countries,
but in there that country,
this is the first water source for them.
And so,
but on that day,
a rebel leader named Morgan of the,
my my,
it's a terrible rebel group there.
Um,
they had been confirmed in 2012,
uh,
of,
of killing,
cooking and eating pygmies thinking that it makes them invincible going into
battle.
But while we were there celebrating,
all of a sudden all the Congolese army,
uh,
is driving by us.
And basically the Congolese army is just a bunch of rebel groups like that,
that,
that defected and came together to be the Congolese army.
And so,
but they're all driving by,
you know,
where we are celebrating.
And uh,
and I guess what it turns out,
these guys have RPGs and machine guns and all sorts of crazy stuff.
And I guess they had a Morgan,
the main leader in the back.
And,
uh,
they had killed him,
but he had came to peacefully turn himself in.
But anyways,
they killed him.
And so that,
that took the,
um,
the,
my mind,
they didn't want to,
the rest of the rebels now they don't want to turn themselves in because if they
turn themselves in peacefully,
then they might be killed or executed,
you know.
So they went back and started killing more,
raping more,
uh,
attacking more gold mine,
stuff like that.
And then,
um,
some of the people there from the UN that were studying the conflict and stuff
said,
be careful in that area where you're going.
Don't go,
um,
for a little bit.
So we stayed for maybe three weeks and then went back out.
But,
uh,
they were saying that the [inaudible] were walking around drinking from all the
pygmy skulls,
just drinking out of there.
Oh,
their school.
So it's,
it's pretty nuts,
man.
Fuck yeah.
Jesus,
man.
You've seen some crazy shit in the few years that you've been down there.
I mean,
what a wild transformation your life has taken going from the ultimate fighter
fighting in the UFC,
experiencing the,
the trip,
the initial trip when you went and you met those people and you became
incredibly committed to helping them.
You just felt like you were overcome with this almost like a calling.
Right.
Is that the best way to describe it and see,
so,
and then you've been there back and forth ever since.
Yeah.
The,
the first time I would say,
it wasn't until my flight back that I felt that initial like,
I got to do something because whenever I was there,
the problem just seems so huge.
And so,
I mean,
so insurmountable that what am I going to do?
How am I going to help?
Um,
and,
and am I going to get endanger myself or get sick or die or whatever in the
process.
Um,
and but on the way back it just felt like,
you know,
if,
if not me then,
then who,
you know,
like they asked me if I would give them a voice if I could help them,
if I could.
Um,
and I just felt,
I dunno,
a yearning and longing that I had to do something.
And,
uh,
so the,
the second trip back,
um,
was,
was great.
I got to actually meet some people that really had some real plans.
Cause the first time I went with people that we didn't have plans to actually
help or anything,
like sustainability was just kind of a learning trip going and seeing what their
problems were.
Second time it was the university,
their,
uh,
their school of community development and they had dreams of,
of giving them water,
given them land,
giving them food,
but they didn't have any way to do it really.
They had the plan and everything in place,
but they didn't have funding behind it.
They didn't have the technology behind it.
Um,
and so the third time was whenever I came back and I,
I had,
uh,
studied how to build those eco domes.
And I partnered with an organization,
it's a great organization called water for and they,
um,
they're big thing is what,
what I was searching for was how to put the,
the tools are basically the power in the hands of the people there instead of
having to have outside help,
how could we actually help them to continue to do it,
continue the process.
And so water four puts the tools in the people's hands and then they teach them
how to do it and then now they can do it for themselves.
It can be a sustainable business forum.
They can,
they can use whatever model they want if it's a nonprofit model,
if it's a business model,
um,
to,
to make it sustainable there so that way yet where I'm at,
Congolese can help Congolese and that way I can hopefully,
you know,
fan the flame,
uh,
go over there to teach them more,
bring over the right people.
Waterfall were really supported and sent over.
Um,
you know,
their director of implementation to come or at least sit down with us for two
weeks,
teach us.
He came back out,
did it again.
Now he's gone over since I've been back already.
He's been back over teaching her team and the more,
you know,
strategies of how to dig these water wells now we had a bunch of people donate
to your cause,
which is,
it's fight for the forgotten.
Um,
we had a bunch of people donate bitcoin and I matched the bitcoin whatever
people donated.
I matched it.
But bitcoin is kind of weird,
like it's fluctuating up and back.
And although I'm a big believer and supporter and I think it probably be better
if people donate cash so we know exactly what the fuck we're dealing with.
What's the best way they can donate to your cause?
Well they could go to fight for the forgotten.com and they can just click donate
and do it.
There are going to be updating the site real soon,
but um,
but yeah,
that's straight to the,
the nonprofit five zero one c three like bank account.
Um,
they can go to water for if they want to fund the projects,
then for a water for water are four,
four,
you are the number,
the number four.
So water in the [inaudible] dot org.
Okay.
Go to fight for the forgotten.com donate or they could go to water for water.
Then the number four,
not flur but the number,
right,
the number.
There you go.
And since coming on the podcast and,
and,
and people becoming aware of what you're doing,
are you getting other organizations that are reaching out to you to try to help
you and to contribute as well?
Yeah,
that's,
that's been a cool thing,
but it's trying to be selective in the process because,
um,
I mean funding is something that,
yeah,
we definitely need,
but at the same time,
we want to do it in a way that's going to be practical for the people there.
So sometimes,
uh,
you have to,
it,
it sucks,
but sometimes you got to say no to good opportunities or,
or,
or chunks of money.
Um,
if they're going to tell you how to use it,
when to use it.
And,
and,
and kind of control if they give it to you with,
with strings attached and set of saying like,
well,
culturally it might not work here.
The doing it that way,
you know,
instead of going and just,
uh,
I don't know if that,
does that make sense?
Well,
sort of like what experiences have you had?
Like what have you had people that just have the wrong idea of what the
environment is like there or what the culture is like?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't wanna I don't wanna knock any organization,
so,
but,
but things have to be sustainable to really continue change.
Um,
my mind frame is that opportunity as much better than charity.
If you give people an opportunity to get out of their poverty,
um,
then that,
that,
that empowers them,
like teach a man to fish.
Absolutely.
And you feed him for a ride,
you know,
give him a fish,
feed him for a day.
And so there's been things where people are like,
Hey,
I'm donating.
Um,
you know,
I had to turn someone away that was going to donate 5,000,
um,
of the water straws.
And that might sound really bad.
I didn't turn them away.
I said,
hey,
how about you help us fund a water?
Well,
like you guys did and I got some pictures to show.
It's awesome with,
uh,
the village you guys supported.
But uh,
but really,
um,
the,
the water straw thing is,
is great.
What's a water straw?
Well,
I don't want to knock them,
but,
but it's,
uh,
I think it's a great organization.
Um,
and,
and I didn't turn the organization down.
It turned up a private person that wanted to say,
hey,
I'm doing this and you,
you run with it.
And I said,
thank you.
But I think a water,
we'll,
we'll support them better then because of had one of those.
It's called a LifeStraw.
And I think the way it's marketed is that it's going to save the third world.
Um,
but then if you think about it,
how many times does someone in the third world,
every single time they want to get a clean drink of water?
Do they want to have a straw wrapped around their neck and then put their face
in the water truck on what exactly is it?
It's like it's a,
it's a filter.
Yeah.
It's a lifestyle and I think it's great.
I think it's great for survival.
Um,
you know,
if,
if you're out camping.
Um,
I also think that because times pull it up,
James.
Yeah.
You say it wraps around your neck.
It wraps around your neck.
You walk around with it.
So,
um,
and then if it,
whenever you need clean water,
you just,
you,
you put your face in the ground in the dirt and then you suck clean water out of
it.
But if a,
that what he was going to support was going to be worth like two or three
different water wells.
And it's a really cool idea.
It's a great,
a great thing.
I really,
I really don't want to them.
I think it's awesome.
This is what we're looking at here.
Yeah.
So he has this whole contraption that you have to put your face in the ground
right there on LifeStraw.
Oh,
it's called a LifeStraw.
Okay.
No,
no,
that's a great marketing.
I agree with that.
You know,
camping,
doing something like that and you need to clean drink of water,
you don't have it.
Right.
Put your face in the ground and get it so he can just drink through that straw.
That's it.
It's clean water.
What about,
but you have to suck pretty hard.
I mean you really do have to pull,
pull on it real hard to get the,
get the water and maybe maybe after you use it a while it gets easier.
I'm sure it does.
That's how in most of those filters are.
But yeah,
but at first you're having to really,
you know,
you're turning red in the face and stuff like that.
So real like inflating of really thick balloon or something like that.
But the opposite and I think it's great.
I really do.
But at the same time to take it in and say to my,
I really think of the pygmies as my family,
I'm not going to go in there and just drop those off.
I'd rather give them a water well that they can go to time and time again,
that just fill up as much as they want.
They can drink it from a glass instead of running a face in the ground.
No.
Well that definitely,
totally makes sense.
Maybe be good to have both.
Yeah,
it,
yeah,
it could be.
It could be.
At the time though,
it was like even getting it over to Congo,
some people are really gung Ho and I love it.
Like,
please help us support us,
things like that.
But then,
um,
if you're going to donate and say this is what it's for and then,
and then we have to find a way to get it there,
ship it,
you know,
5,000 of these straws or something like that.
Um,
it's,
it's a,
it's a lot of work.
So you turned them down because you didn't have the ability to ship them there
or just to ship them.
And then,
and then I was trying to just say,
hey,
this is the real solution that we see right now is,
is that that can be in the future.
And right now I'm in the jungle.
It's hard for me to come out.
Getting things in through customs is crazy.
Also seeing 5,000 of those boxed up,
the Congolese,
a government there in the border patrol,
they're absolutely crazy,
man.
Um,
there was a $3,000 worth of,
of mattresses donated to this hospital and these people sent it on a truck and
paid for the shipping and everything.
Then whenever they got there,
the government wanted $5,000 so that they could bring it into the country.
And they're like,
what do you mean?
So the,
the hospital now has $3,000 of donated mattresses for their,
yeah,
for their beds.
But,
but now they have no way to get it in there because they don't have the funds to
pay $5,000 to the corrupt government officials just to get their beds released
across the border,
all that other stuff that's gotta be insanely frustrating for you trying to make
a change and running time and time again until all this corruption and all these
devious people.
And this,
it sounds like if you go back to the Jamison thing,
it's like this long history of horrible things that have been happening in this
area and there's a kind of like a momentum attached to that.
It's almost like this is just the way it is.
This is a fucked up part of the world.
Does that accurate?
Yeah,
it's,
it's crazy.
It's nuts.
Um,
every single time I've gone across the border,
there's been some of problem where they want to arrest me.
They want to,
in my team,
they want to find someone that they can single out,
find something that they can get a bribe for.
Um,
and,
and they just waste so much of your time.
For instance,
we,
we got a truck donated to us,
which was awesome,
so that we could get our,
our,
our PVC or tools,
all that out to the forest.
And whenever we brought it into the country,
we had all the paperwork saying it's under the university.
It's a tax free basically.
And,
um,
this is a university vehicle is going to be used for humanitarian aid.
Um,
but then whenever we get to the border,
the head guys,
the absolute head guys of customs,
we're saying,
yeah,
but how's that going to feed my family?
And it's like,
well,
it isn't your job,
a government job and they pay you.
It's not my job to pay you.
So they locked up our truck for three and a half weeks.
So we were delayed almost a month and our process and everything,
we had laid out strategies,
we're going to be in this field from this day to this day,
this week to this week,
this month.
So they were just waiting for a bribe.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So after three and a half weeks,
how did you resolve it?
Yeah,
they came back to us with,
with a long list of,
uh,
of new fees of processing fees and we had to go do this to get it and go do
this,
to get and go do this,
to get it.
Um,
and by that time we just decided that I think we ended up paying like $750 to
get our truck released,
but it was going to be,
it was going to be $500 anyways,
so I think they got an extra $250.
But you lost three.
Yeah.
But they were first asking for for seven or $8,000.
They're looking,
they're looking for for 50% of the purchase price of the vehicle.
Oh yeah.
Damn man does it,
it's kind of drive you nuts when you're dealing with something that's,
you know,
you're trying to help you.
You're going over there,
you're essentially dedicated your life,
a huge part of your life to go on over there and helping these people being,
you know,
completely humanitarian and your,
your,
your actions and then you run into this kind of shit.
It's gotta be really,
really frustrating.
Yeah.
I mean it,
it,
it absolutely is.
It's,
it's different than anything that we experienced here.
Cause that corruption isn't,
I mean,
sure,
there's corrupt stuff that goes on here,
but it's not so open.
So public.
Um,
I mean by the time we finally paid that $750,
I remember grabbing my wallet and,
uh,
and because he was,
he was wanting more and I grabbed my wallet and I had like Congolese francs and
my,
my wallet and I just shook it on his desk and he had,
he had other people witnessing this and other people outside.
I could see him.
And I'm like,
here,
this is all I have.
This is all I have.
You've delayed us one month from giving your people,
um,
your countrymen,
water,
like in their dying from it.
And I think right before that,
um,
the little guy named Bob [inaudible] had died.
And,
uh,
I had been holding them in my hands.
And so,
um,
I'm,
I've,
I've buried,
you know,
no,
a couple of kids,
but I've seen,
I've been to over 10 funerals.
Um,
and so,
uh,
I've,
yeah,
I was holding Babo and you know,
I didn't know.
They,
they,
I just got in the hut and,
um,
and whenever I crawled in,
uh,
you know,
his,
his mother is my mother's sister.
So basically she was my aunt and Baba was my cousin.
So Chad was seek,
who was my mother?
Macho is her sister.
And Baba was much of Sun.
And when you say my mother,
like your adopted mother,
my adopted mother there.
And so they just gave you a whole family there.
Yeah,
I love it man.
Wow.
I love him.
My,
my name in that religious Efeosa which fas means the man who loves us.
And then my new name that,
that everyone's been calling me,
especially when I drive up and down the roads there,
um,
is my booty Mongo.
And,
uh,
my booty mung bow means the big,
big me.
And so they can just call me the big pygmy.
And,
uh,
the big pig be in the man who loves us.
And so the thing that was tough with Babu had just passed away before we got the
truck,
I think.
And,
um,
in,
and,
and I actually think Bob,
what happened after a girl named little mill happened before and,
um,
and so it was just,
just tough stuff because I'm seeing this,
it's,
it's really wrecking me,
you know,
seeing kids,
kids go through this,
um,
or anybody really,
and knowing that we have the tools,
we have the solution to that problem.
What was that problem?
What were they dying from?
Water.
Yeah,
just dirty water.
The parasites tapeworms um,
there's other,
there's other kinds of sicknesses that attribute to it,
but most of them,
the little kids,
they run around with these huge bellies and it's just full of tapeworms other
kinds of,
of bacterias and things like that.
And if you can just give them clean water,
I think the stat from the United Nations human development report is 85% of
sickness just disappears once you have clean water in your system.
But once you're,
you're constantly getting sick from that.
And not only that,
but it's diarrhea whenever you have waterborne illness and drinking dirty water.
Now these people that don't have a lot of food,
um,
that are either slaves to get their food,
which a whole family can work,
you know,
mother,
father and their two or three children can go work for their master's and they
get a too small bananas at the end of the day and they have to split that within
the whole family.
But now if you have diarrhea added on top of that,
now you don't absorb any of the nutrients from that banana you just ate.
It just goes straight through you.
Um,
and so it's,
it's real tough to be like me and first we got them land while we were there,
which was,
was a huge thing we negotiated and in petitioned and lobbied for,
for them and their rights with,
with the government there,
but also the,
the local slave masters,
the,
the chiefs of that area.
Um,
and said,
you know,
these are the first citizens of Congo.
Why don't they have any land?
Why all their land been stolen from them?
Why is the land that they're on now all of a sudden legally in the name of
somebody else?
And so we're some land that we could get and purchase on behalf of them.
And uh,
the university did a great job in that.
Um,
I was kind of in the background for that for sure because,
um,
just being,
uh,
in an Ngo and nonprofit,
something like that,
uh,
the local government officials,
again,
we'll see dollar signs.
And so if we were going to buy the land,
um,
there's going to be astronomical.
We couldn't have done it.
If the university would have done it,
they would would've been over $250,000.
Um,
but since we came up with an idea and a solution saying,
well,
who can,
who cares?
Who gets the credit?
Like I don't need it and fight for the forgotten his name.
Like it doesn't have to be in the university's name.
What if we just,
what if we're just kind of the caretakers and we handle the documents and the
negotiations and seeing that it's legally done and then all parties will get
copies of it.
They'll put their thumbprints all on the,
the documents and each chunk of land they have like 10 or 12 thumbprints on it
was signatures and there's a handwritten one and there's a type that one.
And then the government comes out.
Now we're doing gps coordinates of the land,
but the land we got was 2,470 acres.
So we've been able to do that in 10 different spots.
So it's one square kilometer in each,
each different village that we've tried to now establish.
And now we're putting water wells on those and hoping to start farming projects
on a multi.
That's fantastic.
Do you have any concern that with all this added publicity and all this
attention that's in that area,
that the more people will come in and try to exploit that because they know the
resources are in that area now?
I think,
I think what's been great for me is being able to kind of dive in as a part of
the university and have,
they're kind of,
they're covering because now I,
they'd say I'm a teacher,
I'm a prat of,
of appropriate technologies.
Um,
and so I'm teaching Congolese how to,
how to yeah.
Dig Wells farm and,
uh,
build new homes.
Just different sustainable things.
We'll come back here,
learn it,
and then I'll come and I'll either teach it or I'll bring someone with me that
really can,
you know,
even if I don't know the,
everything about it,
I'll get someone there that,
that will.
Um,
and so the university there is,
um,
it's kind of just there.
They're able to really negotiate and show everybody on both sides.
Like,
Hey,
this is in everyone's best interest and would,
which is,
which is something cool because whenever we go in and we drove water wells,
we're not just drilling them for my pygmy family.
We're drilling them for the people that are pressed him too.
And that way we can show him that the project isn't just for the pygmies and
just going to benefit them.
If you can sell us their land,
which sometimes the land prices that we're buying them for our three years,
five years,
10 years salary for the people that,
that either enslaved them or,
or that own that land.
Um,
and then we come in and we say,
we're also going to give you a waterwheel.
Well,
their kids are dying with the same stuff too,
and they've been struggling with diarrhea their whole life or parasites or
whatever it is.
Now we're going to give you guys both water wells in,
when we start our farming project,
we're bringing in a agriculturalist to teach both sides better farming
practices.
Oh,
that's great.
Yeah,
that's a beautiful strategy.
Right?
And so that way it doesn't,
nobody gets offended.
It's like,
Hey,
no,
this isn't,
this isn't a pygmy cause if it's a pygmy project and then that's not going to be
received well,
but people get jealous and then they'll,
and they're,
they're used to pressing them and why are they getting help?
And so we're willing to help everybody out.
Let's,
let's come up together.
Wow.
That's beautiful man.
That's beautiful.
And is there any resistance there?
Because they've been so prejudiced against the pygmies for so long.
Is the,
is there any resistance to the pygmies having equal treatment?
Um,
I,
I'm sure that there,
there is like questions and things like that,
but we haven't seen.
And,
and,
and what we do also is we go in there with the university,
like dean of the,
the um,
department of development and we sit down with them,
we explain everything and it all becomes like agreeable and written down on
paper before we ever take action.
And so that way we can always show them,
hey,
we all agreed to this,
you know,
and,
uh,
so it's,
it's been a great process for me.
Do they all speak the same language,
these people that you're communicating with the pygmies in their oppressors and
what kind of have their own dialects also,
but most people have,
the Congo has so many languages.
There's about 200.
Wow.
Yeah.
200 of their,
of their local tribal languages.
Do they share words in common or is it,
some of them do for sure.
Especially ones that border each other.
But then there's always a common thread.
I think there's five national languages of Congo and um,
is French.
So that's like kind of the government language and the language spoken schools
and other Swahili and that's on the eastern side.
So that's what I've been trying to learn and I can pick it up pretty good.
But a speaking it,
I'm still kind of far behind,
so always have a translator right beside me.
But they have Lingala and they have a,
it's called Banner Congo or something like that.
So it kind of in each region,
the north,
the south,
east,
west,
all that.
They have their own kind of language that everybody speaks.
And then as a nation everybody speaks French.
Wow.
Um,
so you were,
do you speak French at all?
No,
just what do,
how we'll use,
we're using like a program or something like that or books trend you Rosetta
stone.
But really just immersing myself because it's,
it's really hard.
Even the French there is,
I mean,
I guess you could,
French will be good for me to learn.
It absolutely would.
Um,
the communicate with the government officials for sure.
but everybody in the east speaks,
speaks Swahili and my pygmy family,
they speak Swahili,
but it's broken.
And so even like Rosetta stone,
it's a hard thing to go on there and learn because that's the proper Tanzania
and Swahili and then can you kind of gets a little worse.
And then there's a break in between Uganda where and you've gone,
it's basically just the military language of Swahili and then you get over to
Congo and so there's a big break between that,
that pure proper Tanzanian in Swahili and the,
the,
the Swahili is spoken in Congo because they mix in local language and they mix
and French and all that other stem accents.
I'm sure.
Definitely.
So I just tried to immerse myself in there and learn it that way and I'm able to
talk a little bit but,
but really just having a translator there is helping me.
It's amazing how many variations there are in languages.
Yeah.
I went to Northern Ireland,
wants for the UFC and spoke
to people in uh,
in Belfast.
You can't understand a fucking word they're saying,
I mean they're speaking English and you'll pick out like one out of every four
or five words that you,
you're pretty sure that's what the word is.
But they're speaking English.
There's this fucking guy with the thing with today have,
I can tell that guy for him to get off my fucking,
I,
I can get like Whoa,
like,
and they're communicating back and forth to each other like this.
And it sounds like you remember that Cantina scene in Star Wars?
Do you ever seen,
and they're all like speaking on these crazy languages.
That's what it's like.
It's like being in this like weird star port that they're speaking English,
you know?
So yeah,
I met my best friend there,
been he,
he was,
he used to be a translator for the United Nations.
So he speaks fluently seven languages,
but he knows more than that and so fluently.
So he just goes around,
we're,
we're buddies are side by side all the time and he's helping me out.
You have to like,
if you speak fluently seven languages,
you have to kind of practice those languages all the time.
Right.
To keep him fluent.
I'm pretty sure.
But that's what he was doing.
Where I mean,
yes,
but that's what he was doing with is that the United Nations where the,
the Russians,
because he speaks,
I mean,
he's a Congolese guy that's speaking Russian.
I'm like,
that's crazy.
Whenever we see any Russian soldiers,
he would just go on and in a conversation with them.
English is one of,
is not as worse cause he's,
he's great at it.
Um,
but yeah,
all the other languages he's super fluent in.
It's so fascinating.
It's like that story from the Bible about the Tower of Babel.
You know,
that the idea being that this was all like some sort of a plan to keep people
from being able to communicate with each other.
I mean,
it's probably indicative of like how frustrating it must be to realize that
there are,
I mean,
I don't know how many languages there are worldwide,
but I think it's over a thousand,
right?
If there's 200 in Congo,
it's gotta be,
yeah.
Imagine.
I mean,
I mean how the f until you have some sort of a program that translates an
ordinance still until someone creates a universal language and gets people to
adopt it.
But Shit,
we won't even adopt the metric system.
You know?
I mean,
when I was in high school,
they tried that shit.
They tried to push the,
someday everyone's going to be on.
And I remember everyone in the class like,
fuck this,
nobody's going to adopt this.
You know,
we,
we lived 15 years learning about inches and yards and we're not into meters.
You know,
we don't really care.
And it's,
it seems like it's incredibly frustrated for people to communicate without some
sort of a universal translator,
whether it's a program or something,
but even then without a universal language,
it's,
it's gonna be really hard for people to relate to each other and to,
to not like,
it's,
it's easy to look at someone who's speaking some crazy language like people in
Afghanistan or people in Saudi Arabia and think of them as like,
not us,
because they don't,
they don't speak the way we speak.
If we heard someone in Afghanistan speaking total fluent English,
we would think of them way different than if you hear them in some crazy Arabic
language.
W W W we totally don't understand.
Yeah,
yeah.
Without a doubt.
Language is something that I wish I had a gift at.
Uh,
like I,
I just,
I really wish I could just grasp it and speak it so well,
but I really think just immersion into it as the way that you really start to,
to pick it up.
Cause I,
I found myself just,
you know,
able to start learning Swahili and then someone's over to the side and they make
a little joke and I could,
I would be able to start laughing with them.
You understand the jokes?
Yeah.
Sometimes like sometimes for sure.
What's a good Swahili joke?
Good Swahili joke.
Um,
I'm not,
I'm not sure.
It was like walking into a bar.
Yeah.
Well they cost Mizunos have diarrhea.
Ah,
like would they call you what?
Mizzou.
That's what guys called tits,
isn't it the same thing with zoom.
Google does or something like that.
I'm a zoom.
Google is definitely,
they just mean that for white men.
That's why Healy was,
was zoom,
Google Muslim girl,
Muslim group.
Is that,
um,
like derogatory,
like how ugly like Hawaiians call?
Uh,
it,
I think it is,
but to them it's so,
it's so a,
I embrace it though.
I embrace it and I'll say it with them if the kids are saying it and stuff like
that.
Um,
but for them it's just more everybody sticks to their tribe.
And I think that's a problem with some of the violence that goes on there.
I mean,
a lot of times you'll hear people in Congo seeing that in other parts of Africa,
San,
well,
we weren't the ones that chose the boundaries of our country,
you know,
is the people that colonized and stuff like that.
And so we would have been off on her own and in this region because this is our
language and this is our tribe.
And so there,
I think that's why there's a lot of tribal conflict and things like that in
different languages.
And so people will,
will pride themselves in their culture,
which I,
I love cultures.
It's,
it's great.
Um,
the pygmy culture's awesome.
In fact,
I mean there's,
there's like some great photos in there of,
of,
of hunting and a little boy getting his first hunt,
which was great as named Sam g in the same village that you guys sponsored a
water well for.
Um,
and so I love cultures and this little boy,
what did he hunt with?
Is these spear the spear?
He got forest antelope.
Oh,
I was there and had just woke up.
And uh,
this is early in the morning.
I don't know if you can tell.
It's kind of like how tall is that little fella?
Uh,
he's,
he's a little dude.
I,
there's another picture of me standing by him,
so you'll see,
but he got it with a spear that's beer that he's holding.
That seems like a heavy spear for a little guy like that.
It's his great grandfather spirits.
So his grandfather took them out hunting while he was on that.
Got It.
Oh,
he's got these and there's the head.
So there's it.
And if you go to the next one,
there's a,
it's called a,
I think they call it a Janae or spotted [inaudible].
It's almost like a more like a mongoose,
but it's kind of like in the leopard fee.
I mean like it'd be like a cross between a mongoose and a leopard or something.
A small leopard.
Cause they're,
they're pretty small in size.
Next picture shot.
They eat that.
Yeah,
totally delete everything,
man.
Wow.
So,
so you can tell small.
Yeah.
How old is that little dot.
I think he's probably around 12.
They don't know their age,
so wow.
They don't know their age.
That's fascinating.
So there's some of the men in the village,
but a few,
if you go back to that last one,
you can even see,
uh,
the bellies on the little guys down right there.
You can see the affected bellies of,
of different kinds of parasites and sickness or disease.
That is nuts,
man.
And these people have a clean water.
Well now.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Do you have to give them medicine to get rid of that belly or does it go,
does it go away?
Just with clean water?
It doesn't go away just with clean water,
but,
but the sickness drops,
um,
about 85%.
But what we do is we have,
um,
different nurses and things that,
that are partnered with the university and we send them out and they,
the pills are like,
I mean,
a dollar for like 10 of them.
And you can give one pill to each of them.
It's not a fun process,
man.
They either vomit or,
or,
or have to,
they have to get the worms out of them.
It's the kill these biological entities inside their body.
So it's poisoned.
Essentially.
I saw the type of poison,
right.
Definitely in the,
and they,
I mean,
I've seen mounds of,
of these,
I mean,
it's mixed with other stuff,
but just stumbled upon it and bins like,
oh,
that's because we gave him the pill.
Like,
and I'm like,
what is that in there?
And there was tape worms,
all insight,
this mound of,
of,
of feces on one of the trails that were hiking.
Wow.
So,
um,
and how come the adults don't have it?
They have flat stomachs.
Um,
I think as they get older,
I mean,
I'm not 100% sure,
but I think their body just starts learning to fight it better.
And some of them have had the medicine and so they'll,
there'll be smarter and,
and try not to,
to,
to drink dirty water whenever we're just from anywhere.
When these,
when these little guys are walking around now they're being taught you have a
clean source of water.
This is where you get your water from.
And they can carry little containers or bottles and,
and,
and take those around with them.
And they do most of their hunting with spears.
Uh,
most of bows and arrows I think.
But they'll,
they'll drive them into nets.
And the,
if you keep going down,
there'll be a picture of the net.
So,
um,
but they had these nets,
Etsy.
Yup.
And they just go and they break,
uh,
these little trees that are starting to grow there,
maybe three foot tall.
They break them in and they lay a net,
uh,
the top of the net on it.
And then they just kind of weave them in and out of the forest.
And then what they do together is maybe they get leafs,
maybe they see an animal and they just drive it into these nets sometimes.
Uh,
like with monkeys and parrots and stuff like that.
They're using their,
um,
their bows and arrows,
which if you go up one picture that shows the,
the little boys,
I mean,
even from that age right there,
uh,
those little boys are just nailing anything.
I mean,
you give them a target.
Uh,
my,
my wife and I would,
uh,
would get passion fruit and we,
what we do is we,
we have through,
there's a rotten one.
If there's an empty one,
um,
we would,
we would roll it to him and these guys could hit the moving like this age right
here.
Uh,
which I don't know.
What do you think?
That's five,
five years old.
They could hit a moving passion fruit target that we're rolling.
They could just nail them with their bows and arrows.
Wow.
There's even a,
a short video I got of a,
of them nailing a,
uh,
a mouse.
That's what it is.
A mouse.
There's a mouse in the village and they wanted to show off to,
to Emily.
Um,
that's my wife.
And,
uh,
she came to visit and it was just,
it was just really fun because they,
she wanted to experience their culture and whenever you show them interest in
the culture,
they get really,
really good.
Decided.
Is this the video?
Yeah,
there's the mouse running.
I don't know if you can see it around here and around there,
but it's,
it's definitely alive moving.
And I just said,
hey,
shoot it and uh,
and just nailed it.
It was like a foot away and I'm not that impressed.
But did they eat that mouse?
Yeah,
they'll eat it.
They'll eat it.
And then,
um,
they'll even do,
like turtles.
They'll,
they'll go out and they'll make backpacks out of turtles.
Um,
it sounds crazy,
but they'll,
they'll go out and to look for the antelope or something like that.
And then if they come across a turtle,
they'll make out of a,
I don't know,
these little fines,
uh,
literally just backpacks where they tied onto the legs of the turtle and they
walk around with it.
And if they find a big thing in meat,
then they,
they let the turtle go.
But if,
if they don't,
if they come back empty handed day,
they're going to come back with the turtle.
And these,
these arrows that they use,
like what,
what did they use for like the,
the,
the feathers for the fledglings and all the feathers or leafs leaving.
They make a small slit in the back of the,
the Arrow and then they slide in the leaf that that's formed just like a
feather.
And when they,
when they use the tips,
what's the tip?
The tip can be metal.
If they find scrap metal somewhere,
they can beat it down and,
and uh,
yeah,
it turned it into little Varage hard.
Yeah.
But then sometimes they have these wicked barbs on them too.
Um,
and then what they use most though,
they would use,
they would use a,
the metal on smaller game,
but on bigger game they use their poison tipped arrows.
So they just have it in wood and they sharpen it down and they kind of do the
spiral at the tip of the Arrow.
And then what they do is they take roots and berries and um,
I think that's,
that's pretty much it.
But they get like a,
basically like poisonous cocktail.
They make an,
it turns black and then they dip the tip of the Arrow right in it.
And that's what they use for,
for something.
They really want to get a monkey or an antelope or anything like that.
And when they do that,
doesn't that poison the meat?
They eat it and I eat it.
So,
um,
I guess it could,
I didn't ever think of that.
Maybe I should be careful.
Well,
I would wonder like how's the poison work and if that's the case,
how do you not ingesting and maybe it is it local is like only the spot where
the Arrow hits.
That doesn't seem to make sense though.
Where the bloodstream,
maybe once you drain the blood out of it,
they shoot it and then they just track it and then once it falls over dead,
they just put it over their shoulders and bring it back.
How long do they have to try?
I like,
how long does it take before the poison kills him?
This will be kind of funny.
I can't really,
um,
follow them very well through the forest.
I,
I'm,
I'm just being and clunking around.
I got hiking boots on or whatever,
but they're just fast and quiet.
So I've tried to go out on a couple of months with them,
but,
uh,
I,
I knew they were just kind of humbly like being nice,
like letting me experience their culture.
But then I realized these guys are quick,
they're quiet and I'm not,
and so I better just let them go off on their own and do their thing.
Do they hunt barefoot?
So yeah,
they do everything bare for everything.
Most,
most time,
everything barefoot.
They,
if they can find like most of the things that they're wearing on their body is
because they've worked for someone or,
or,
or been a slave for some women that was part of their payment was,
was clothing.
Why clothing or shoes or things like that.
But it's their,
their culture is just to run around barefoot everywhere.
May a tough feat.
It's,
it's,
it's pretty cool to see like just their feet,
the structure of their feet.
They don't have the real high arches and it's not real soft skin,
you know?
But they can just,
they can just book it through the forest and step on stuff that I'm feeling
through my boots.
But they just,
they just keep going.
Yeah.
Do you ever see that show a dual survivor?
Just like,
I don't think it's on anymore,
but yeah.
Yeah.
That guy is crazy.
The guy walks around barefoot everywhere.
Everywhere.
Yeah.
He does everything,
Cody,
isn't it?
Yeah.
He's a,
he's a,
an odd character.
Like he has this house that he built that's some sort of a sustainable house.
It's got,
you know,
I think in what uses like a sod for the roof or something like that.
And then his whole deal is like surviving with minimal equipment,
but he does everything barefoot.
He runs around barefoot and his feet are like this thick skins.
Disgusting.
You don't want to give that due to foot massage.
Yeah.
He probably wouldn't fill it.
Well it's like a shoe.
I mean he wears a permanent shoe.
I guess that's like really what's supposed to happen to people,
you know?
Yeah,
I think so too.
Um,
but it's kind of funny,
like,
you know,
you don't,
for martial arts,
but like the bottom of your heel,
you could fucking pound on things with your heel,
but like that same impact on your Shin would be very painful.
You know?
It's kind of interesting how that works.
Yeah.
Uh,
even on the ultimate fighter West Sims,
when I fought him,
I mean it was like a minute and a half finally got him to the ground in and put
them in an arm triangle.
But,
but before that he fractured a,
a smell I liked.
It was a small fracture,
hairline fracture in my foot with just a couple of foot stomps.
I mean,
he just did it a couple times.
I was like,
Dang,
I've never,
you know,
we didn't train for that in the,
in the gym and stuff.
So I never felt that before.
But right when he did,
I knew whenever,
whenever the hairline fracture came.
Yeah.
Just being able to stomp with that is
yeah.
But yeah,
the heels amazingly powerful,
which is one of the reasons why I've been sort of a proponent for no gloves.
I kind of,
I've been on this kick for like a few months now.
I mean,
I'd always been aware that gloves really protect the hands more than they,
uh,
protect,
the opponent definitely.
You know,
they really protect the guy who's using the gloves more than the guy who,
who you're hitting with.
I think it's kind of unnatural in a way.
And I think it's also unrealistic like wrist wraps as well,
wrist wraps and gloves.
I think those probably contribute more to a poet's getting hurt then.
Then anything sort of like the same argument that a lot of people think that
football would be safer if people knew more helmets.
If you can,
we'll kick somebody in the head with your heel,
which is like one of the most powerful kicks he can throw.
Like go to,
it's like Barboza.
Yeah,
Edson Barboza and Terry Edom,
which is what crazy Raisie knock out the first knockout ever in the UFC from a
wheelchair.
But if that is legal like and you could spin and kick someone with the heel,
why do your knuckles have a pad on them?
That seems completely ridiculous to me.
It doesn't make any sense.
And it seems also like an unrealistic depiction of martial arts.
Of course,
if you want to go that route,
you would say,
well you shouldn't work cops either.
Cause that's kind of unrealistic to yeah,
I like wearing that.
Yeah.
I'm not a big fan of kicking people in the balls.
But even even with the gloves,
being able to hook into it,
you know,
to it and pool.
I mean that,
that's a little trick that everyone guys use that for,
to submit guys too.
I've seen guys get,
he chokes and get teens where they'll hook their own glove and use it to finish
a choke because it's like you can get some mad leverage along with like grabbing
it and that guy's not gonna be able to hand fight it very easy.
Yeah,
no man.
Once you hook it,
you're allowed to hook your own gloves too,
which is nothing.
You're allowed to Hook your own.
You're allowed to grab your own shorts,
like say if a guy is trying to,
yeah.
If you Tris guys trying to get you in a Kimora,
you can grab your own shorts and hold on.
As long as they're not,
as long as they're not his.
Wow.
Yeah.
It was just kind of squirrely,
you know?
But that's,
it's a frustrating thing too when you see two guys grapple and,
um,
one guy is trying to take down the other guys grabbing the guy shorts and the
referee will say stop and they will stop.
But that brief moment where they held on might've been just enough for them to
scoot their hips out and,
and defend.
Yeah.
You know,
I think everybody should wear tights too.
I think everybody should wear like old school Marco who asked Little Bikini
briefs.
That'd be great.
Dennis Hallman.
Yeah.
Like Dad,
it's all,
but then it's almost like,
oh,
you almost got fired from the UFC for that man.
I think so.
I think there's almost a slip.
Yeah.
Well apparently he lost a bet.
So Dennis Hallman came out.
See if you can find a picture of that acts.
They're hilarious.
Dennis Hallman came out with the smallest bikini briefs and man pathways
probably of all time.
It was pretty ridiculous.
I don't remember man.
I think it has.
Yeah,
there,
there are down there.
I think training mills a lot.
It was a training task.
I think it is.
Yeah.
That is what it,
but meanwhile,
why is that?
Homoerotic like why is everybody upset about that?
But like,
you know,
if they're longer shorts,
I mean his junk has covered up or we terrified of the upper thigh.
Like what is it?
What is everyone afraid of?
How come you can see his nipples?
Nobody freaks out.
You know,
and what he freaks out,
the guy's bare chested,
but for some reason having little shorts on as offensive.
Yeah.
I don't get it.
That was even the thing I would do to joke around with guys was where Montes uh,
that Wayans cause he couldn't look into my eyes serious if I had these,
these leopard a man panties on with,
with sequins and things like that.
Kept guys from looking into your eyes.
Well they would grant or something like that,
you know,
they wouldn't like really do the deep stare down,
if that makes sense.
You made a post like a recently,
like within the last six months saying that you were considering,
uh,
coming back to finding potentially,
yeah.
I mean I think I should give it a shot.
Um,
how old are you now?
27.
He's still young.
I'm a year younger than the youngest dude.
I thought.
So in my 15 fights,
the youngest guy was 28 years old.
Now I think I was 19 or 20.
And so,
I mean,
I think that that the reason I would want to really at least give it my full
effort,
at least for a season,
at least for a year to see what,
see what I can do.
See,
I'm not taking,
you know,
big really tough fights,
right when I come back.
But to build my way back up,
um,
because if I could use the platform,
if fighting to,
and the name of,
of the nonprofit is fight for the forgotten,
if I could literally fight for the forgotten and,
and,
and fulfill my first promise to give them a voice.
The man I'm passionate about both those are like my two greatest passions,
you know,
is,
is MMA.
I can't,
I can't stay away from it.
And Congo,
if I got to the Internet,
it was,
yeah,
it was straight up the Eugene t yeah,
the underground.
It was what I had to check.
The first thing I was on was had to get my MMA fix.
And then,
I mean,
I'm so passionate about the pygmies and uh,
and seeing just,
just what I can do.
I mean,
there's even a,
uh,
an African proverb or Congolese proverb about mosquitoes and it says,
if you think you're too small to make a difference,
try sleeping in a room with a mosquito,
is there to try sleeping in a closed room with a mosquito.
And so,
um,
I just think that,
that,
that me and my mind,
like at first when I got there,
it was like there's no way I can make a difference.
Um,
and then,
and then I met some great people that already were,
had a heart for it.
And then if I could use fighting as a platform,
um,
I'm passionate about it.
If he use a platform to say,
Hey,
from my wind bonus,
we're going to buy this much more land,
we're going to drill three more water wells,
we're going to fund this new farming project.
Um,
I think if I didn't do it,
I'd be an old man one day wondering what if,
what if I would've tried it?
You know,
and if I just went to the jungle because I would love,
I mean,
I feel like I could be completely content with living in a twig and leaf hut
for,
I don't know,
maybe the rest of my life,
at least for a while.
But if I just did that,
then you know that nobody's going to know about it.
Nobody is going to support it.
Um,
and so if I could use this as a,
as just a tool,
a platform,
um,
I would have to take it super serious.
There's no way I could just,
you know,
lackadaisically come back into fighting.
But um,
but I've been training at all.
I'm getting back into it with a team take down and Dallas Fort Worth.
Okay.
So you,
are you living out there now?
Yeah,
I am.
So that's where a great spot.
It's a great place to train.
Yeah.
Do that.
I love how Mark Lehman trains just,
he's a genius.
Yeah.
I mean I've,
I've never seen it in a gym.
Maybe you have out here in Cali,
but we,
we walk into the cage or they do,
I've only done a few times there,
but that's going to be my gym I think.
And so whenever,
whenever you walk in,
he's got the,
the flat screens all around the cage and he's got his,
his Mac and a,
if he's showing you a move,
he'll show you three,
four,
five fights that he's,
that this move has been finished in the UFC or the promotions.
And I'm so if you doubt them,
he's going to say,
hey,
pull up to his assistant will say,
pull this,
this fight up to this,
you know,
this much into it.
And then he'll start breaking down the fight,
breaking down the move,
the setup and how to finish.
So I think it's great.
Yeah,
he's a wizard when it comes to MMA knowledge and Jujitsu knowledge.
Like he always has been like,
he's always been like completely engrossed in the world as you Jitsu.
He was one of those guys like way back in the day that had like all these moves
categorized and he had like folders and files for basically every mall.
I'd never even heard of anybody that like sort of broke it down the way he did.
Yeah.
So that,
that's what I love about that team.
Whenever I walked in there I was thoroughly impressed because they treat it like
any other,
like a professional sport.
Yeah.
You walk in and the water,
the supplements,
the whatever you need is at your disposal.
And then whenever you get in there to train,
you have five full time coaches that are paid,
you know,
just to train you.
So he had a lot of focus and the,
their,
their training the guys really,
right.
I like what they're doing with heavyweights actually with a row shalt,
um,
he's training five days a week.
And what I used to do is always train six days a week and I train two to three
times a day.
And that's what Brendan would do.
And that's what Shane would do.
And that's what,
you know,
I think attributed to a lot of our,
our,
our injuries.
But with Rochelle,
they train five days a week and make sure they're getting his cardio up,
but he can't train like a,
125 pounds or hundred 35 pounder.
It were heavyweights are taking more of a pounding on their body.
So you got to find a way to,
to,
to not just train harder but train smarter.
That's interesting.
Um,
is it just because of the,
the gravity just carrying the extra weight,
the pressure on the joints?
Like,
why do you think that a heavyweight can only train five days a week?
Like what is it?
I don't think they can only train five days a week,
but I think it's a smart move for Roche Shelton and I think it would be a smart
move for me to do to um,
and maybe other guys would adopted.
I don't know.
But for me,
whenever you look at the heavyweight division,
I mean,
they can end the fight at any minute,
you know,
and you look at the one 45,
one 35 one 25,
the smaller guys,
they're really exciting fights.
Super talented guys.
Worldclass without a doubt.
But sometimes there's just not the same weight and power behind their punches.
I'm behind their takedowns behind everything.
I mean,
it goes from,
you know,
255 pounders equal almost one of us,
they're a little more than one of us.
And then,
then now you have 500 pounds colliding into the mat whenever you're taking
someone down or punching.
There's just all this stuff that,
that I think you take a lot more of a beating on your body.
Well,
certainly cardio wise,
it's very different.
That's what makes Kayne so unique is that he,
he can keep up a pace that's usually reserved for people that are like one 70,
he can do at two 40.
He's,
he's so unique in that way.
Right.
And maybe if on the,
if you're going to train six days,
it's something that's specifically about recovery or cardio or both.
Um,
because the way that we were doing it at grudge and that's a worldclass gym.
I love it.
But,
um,
something I look back and see from assessing just,
just my opinion as me and we were,
we were,
you know,
three days a week,
training,
sparring hard and for heavyweight sparring hard,
three days a week,
you're taking your,
you're taking a lot of punishment.
You're dishing out a lot of punishment and so were,
were,
you don't even have time on Sunday.
It's not,
it's not enough time to,
to rest him,
to recuperate and to,
for your body to heal up.
Yeah.
Especially if you're sparring Shane fucking car.
Well Yeah Dude,
that guy,
that guy.
It was scary.
It was still still still scary.
Absolutely.
But whenever he would,
he would throw a hook.
You would,
your body would,
would quake,
it would stand like a ripple effect through your body.
You know,
he's a big boy.
Yeah.
Big Ass bones to yeah.
And again,
his issue,
it was the same issue.
It was cardio.
I mean go to the Brock Lesnar fight me,
he had Brock Lesnar all but out in that first round,
but the second round came around and he just was spent,
he just emptied his gas tank in that first round.
And if you,
if you look at it though,
he,
he was,
I mean if you look at how he's training,
he was training six days a week and so somehow that cardio didn't come and even
training six days a week.
So,
um,
I don't know what the,
I think maybe it was also that adrenaline dump.
It think he's going to finish off brush,
all that other stuff.
Who forgot to three tables talking about how when he was punching him,
you literally forgot to breathe because he was just figured like let's just
sprint and this is going to be the end here.
It was very close to me and then so I could,
I can understand what his mind frame was as close as you could ever get.
I mean,
it was like it many people would have stopped that fight.
Many refs would have stopped that fight.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's cool they gave,
I mean it's cool they gave brocket chance to,
to recover.
I mean I,
I,
I love Carlin and he's a great friend and he's good,
great,
great person.
But it's,
it's cool to see whenever a guy can have that time to recover and see during the
round them recovering and come back and win.
Yeah,
that was an issue this weekend.
I'm like the Dan Henderson fight in particular,
like that fight was stopped.
Yeah.
Like fairly quickly.
He got tagged by Gago Musashi.
And in a way I kind of understand because I think that a referee,
sometimes we'll look at a guy who was older and judge it slightly differently
than a guy,
like maybe say who's,
who's younger,
like,
uh,
like frank.
I always go to this one example,
Frankie Edgar Gray Maynard,
they could have stopped that fight multiple times and Frankie came on to stop
gray Maynard in the second fight.
Wow.
You know,
I mean,
it was a,
is an amazing,
amazing fight.
But
if you go back in and watch that fight,
watch that first round.
There's so many moments where you say,
like,
if a guy was quick to pull the trigger,
it could be over.
And not everybody's Frankie Edgar either like the other one was,
um,
uh,
this weekend,
Andy Ogel and uh,
I don't want to mispronounce his name,
so let me say it right now.
The guy from that was finished,
but from my rack,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
hold on one second.
I shouldn't miss miss that fight.
It didn't see it.
Makwan Amr kind of who is a bad motherfucker.
This kid,
first of all,
this kid goes into the octagon and does these perfect flips like,
and you get like right away you can say like,
Whoa,
this kid is like a serious gymnast.
And then hits Andy Yoga with this ridiculous flying knee like a launched across
the rank tags,
him and his flying knee and then tags them and the number God,
and then the referee stopped the fight.
And I even said,
I probably shouldn't have said that.
I,
I thought it was a premature stoppage.
The referee could see better than I can obviously,
like whether or not a guy's eyes rolled behind his head,
but you know,
Andy Yoga was pretty upset and maybe I was going on that,
but the,
the stoppage in that fight was,
it's certainly more understandable,
I think.
Then the Henderson fight,
the Henderson fight was like one shot and he went down and then stomach.
Well,
he tagged him mean he was kind of grazing,
but it was kind of like the temple area,
which always fucks with your equilibrium.
Yeah.
But this,
uh,
Amir Khan,
he hit him with this flying knee.
Like he traveled so far.
Like if you watch the flying knee,
see him,
you could find it.
Jamie is,
is opening move.
He hits him with this ridiculous flying knee.
I mean,
it was just,
he launched himself like 14,
15 feet across the kid's a freak athlete,
man.
And I'd heard that about him entering into this fight is a fight.
Eight seconds.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it was amazing.
He's a,
he's pretty impressive.
That's great.
He said what he said about me,
I thought he,
I thought he was a drunk.
That's what he said about me.
He's a funny dude,
man.
He's got a lot of personality too,
He's very funny.
Very funny.
But find the fight itself.
Don't just pull shit up.
I think.
I think the thing with a,
you can't look at it without us seeing it.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Oh,
but the audience doesn't see it.
Is that what's going on?
Oh,
okay.
That's fine.
Um,
but,
uh,
I think with that Dan Henderson fight,
I think maybe the,
the angle because I watched a couple of times and I think maybe the angle of the
ref,
he was kind of maybe behind kind of a massage.
He,
whenever he,
he,
he hit him.
And then whenever,
whenever Hindou's head kind of hit the back of the cage,
maybe that,
that scared the ref and prompted him to stop it early.
I always wonder when you go to new places to whether or not commissions are more
sensitive,
you know,
because maybe Sweden has like less sensitive.
Uh,
we're were,
referees are more sensitive to fighters getting injured.
We find that in Boston and Boston is stop cuts.
They stop fights on cuts way quicker than other places.
Like Mark [inaudible],
who's from Boston told me they've always had issues with that.
I can Boston when fighters get cut,
they'll stop it way quicker than they would say in Vegas.
Where these all Swedish reps kind of from that area?
No.
Um,
a lot of the guys were English guys.
it was,
it was different.
I know in a,
in Finland they have the brutal MMA that you can headbutts still and in Finland
stuff,
right?
Isn't that right?
Is that what I mean they at least a couple of years ago and whenever I went to
golden glory out in Amsterdam and I was training with Allister for a bit,
but also,
uh,
do you remember John Olive and Emo?
Yeah.
Thank you John.
All of animal animal who is a,
uh,
Abu Dhabi champion.
Yeah.
Fantastic grappler.
Absolutely a beast on the ground.
He was like,
I dunno,
like a spider in his legs and everything was,
were,
were nuts,
how they could wrap around you.
Um,
but he was from Norway and there MMA,
they just,
they,
they were very,
very resistant.
And this was when I was training with him back in like 2008,
I think.
But they're very,
very resistant to,
I thought it was a brutal barbaric sport,
all that.
But then in Finland,
just a couple of countries away,
he could still head button.
That's where he's getting some of his first fights,
I think.
Wow.
It was just such a contrast and how they viewed the sport.
This is the flying knee wash.
His kid
kid just flies out.
Wow.
I mean it was cool.
It was a quick stop.
But man,
that kid that flying,
he's an athlete.
Fucking incredible.
Look at that.
And you only took like three or four steps before he launched in there.
Wow.
Yeah.
Now ogle tried to ref tackle the referee,
which is always bad.
I just,
you know,
I get sensitive because Olga was in the cage.
He was super freaked out and upset.
He thought the fight was stopped too quickly.
It's weird.
Dang man.
It's hard to say when to stop and when not to.
It's hard.
You want to give a guy a chance to recover,
but you also want to save the guy from unnecessary punishment if he can't defend
himself.
Absolutely.
They have the fucking hardest job in the world next to fighters.
His referees.
Yeah.
I mean I wouldn't want to know all the backlash that they get.
I think it's like fighters,
number one.
Of course.
Referees,
number two,
judges three for some of the,
I think I'm way down the line.
It's like Bruce buffers jobs probably harder than mine.
I mean my job is,
I'm just reacting to things,
you know,
the only time it becomes an issue,
it's like things like if I'm critical of a stoppage or from critical of judging
and then it becomes a point of debate.
But I think that the controversy,
you know,
especially subjective controversy,
whether it's a,
you,
you can agree or disagree,
I think it's important because it starts the discussion.
Like,
you know,
what should be legal,
which shouldn't be legal,
what should happen,
what shouldn't happen.
Like there's a lot of people that have like some really strong feelings about
the shape of the gloves right now and the,
that they're contributing to.
I pokes and that's something I've had some recent conversations with Dana and
with Lorenzo and they're of opinion.
I think that,
uh,
the fighters need to be penalized more because they'd gloves been the same for a
long time.
But back in the day it wasn't nearly as much of an issue.
If you go back to like,
you know,
UFC 37 and a half or UFC 40 or UFC,
you don't see a lot of Ipos but now it's hard to go one fight or one event
rather without a couple of fights.
Having I poke issues.
It's super common and I think maybe you can attribute that to a lot of Moy Thai
training because a lot of guys are doing this,
which is really common in Muay Thai and step in with knees and you know all
these guys who do these things with gloves on,
which are,
you know,
totally fine with a glove on and you're palming the guy's face with a glove on
it and throwing leg kicks or a knee or elbows behind it.
But doing those fucking fingers,
man,
fingers just go in the eyes so much.
It drives me crazy.
Then we see guys like Bisping who's,
he's got one eye that looks completely different from his other eye now because
of surgery,
detached retina surgery and then they have to put oil inside his retina.
And I don't even know how much he can see out of his right eye.
But when you look at him in the eyes,
he's,
his one eye looks very different than the other guy.
The other eye,
Alan Belcher,
same thing.
Even Anthony Johnson have problem with that,
right?
Yeah.
With Kevin Burns,
he had Kevin Burns poked him in the eye and then in this fight Gustafson
accidentally poked him and tie it.
They're totally accidental,
but it's like this thing where guys are doing that.
Jon Jones is the number one guy as far as,
uh,
like the controversy because he's so tall and long.
That's an excellent strategy to,
he's almost like doing that cartoon thing where he puts his gun to your head and
you're swinging because he can't reach him.
Yeah.
So I wonder if there's a way to cover the fingers.
You know,
I've always wondered,
I mean,
this is kind of hypocritical because I think they shouldn't be wearing gloves at
all,
but I wonder if there's a way to like put like some sort of a soft leather over
the tips of the fingers.
Like have the,
you know,
those old school Everlast boxing club,
those bad glove.
I remember those.
They had the little Barnes had them almost.
Yeah.
They had the bar inside of him.
I don't know why they had the bar.
Why was the bar there?
I Dunno.
It doesn't make any sense.
But those,
those gloves,
um,
almost like would be better.
Like some people think that it would be bad for grappling because the fingers
would not,
it wouldn't work as individuals,
but you never really do this anyway.
You know,
if you use your thumbs at all,
you kind of use it like this.
It's very rare that you hook a finger and the thumb together.
I think the pride gloves,
you weren't really,
they were more,
we have a pair of them around here somewhere.
We have a pair of him still the pride gloves,
they had far less problems,
but you know,
cro,
cop and Josh Barnett,
that was an issue.
Um,
I mean it gets it,
it happens.
Guys get poked in the eye.
It's almost like,
it seems like it's inevitable.
But Dana,
his opinion is that they should be panelized every time there's an eye poke one
point,
which yeah,
I mean it's pretty harsh,
but you wouldn't do it.
Yeah.
I've never had an in my fights in a row at a problem.
Uh,
the pride gloves or Blue Jamie.
Yeah.
I never had a problem with poking the guy in the,
I got poked in the eye once and it absolutely sucks because for the whole round,
my,
my vision was,
was like it would double and it would turn black and it would just,
it just jacked with me.
The tie around.
These are the prog drugs.
Um,
Brian from London real gave me these.
That's awesome.
Thank you Brian.
Um,
he has of history.
Yeah.
These are a,
nobody fought with these on,
but these are the lists,
the original pride gloves.
There's so they're very different and either there's a pronounced curve to them
that you don't get from the,
uh,
the,
the gloves the UFC uses ever last,
which is now a sponsor of the UFC or,
uh,
I don't know if you'd say sponsor or a partner or they're working together with
the UFC.
I guess we're going to use the Everlast close.
Everlast has an excellent MMA glove that is more curved than the,
uh,
the ones that we use now.
These all sore longer.
They're easy to,
to form to,
well,
whenever you get those UFC gloves,
you,
you instantly have to start breaking them in,
you know,
and so I could see the argument of it making it harder to close your hand
sometimes.
Cause if they're not broken in like this,
then it's like these automatically make your hands curve.
Like automatically.
It's like by default your hand wants to curve.
I would think these would be,
why don't they just go back to fucking pride club?
I don't understand.
I don't have to go back to this.
This seems like a good glove.
Yeah,
absolutely man.
I dunno.
I just feel like there's a better way.
And I feel like if you do,
you know,
that's that expression,
like what's the definition of insanity?
Doing the same thing over and over again expecting a different result.
Right now it's just this,
it seems like the gloves that we have now,
everyone says the same thing.
Every fighter that I've talked to that it,
it actually,
they make your hands straight now,
especially as your hands fatigue as the rounds go on.
They literally make your hands straight now.
But the Bella tour gloves that they're using that Everlast designed or far more
curved,
so Everlast has like their own sort of,
um,
patented technology,
their patented design and uh,
they're also having less handbrakes to,
uh,
I didn't know that at all.
Yeah.
Beltour did,
they did some sort of a study on handbrakes before the new gloves and hand after
the new gloves and they have much less breaks after the new gloves because of
the shape of it and the support on the top of the glove.
It lends more support to the metacarpals guess.
Well,
I dunno.
Just seem,
but then again,
like I said,
I think they should be bare knuckled.
I really do.
I think if you can hit,
so the Shin,
I was just about to ask you that.
Do you think you'd ever go back to that?
Not Right.
I think it's too ingrained or to adopt it two part of the culture now.
I don't know man.
It's a weird thing.
It's like why?
Why is everybody so hung up on like everything's staying the same?
First of all,
I think cups.
Cups are a huge guy.
Damn issue.
All right guys get hit with glancing blows to the sac and they go down.
I think there's a lot of guys that were really shitty cups.
Like there's some like you've seen if you're worn the diamond MMA,
I heard them get them when we have him in the box suite.
That's awesome.
It gives you one had one and it might not fit your fucking,
yeah,
giant strapping glutes you savage.
But uh,
if they do fit,
see if you get a larger extra,
probably extra large,
whatever the bigger ones are.
But diamonds figured out a way to make this compression short with all these
straps.
And this cop that is like sort of,
it's got a rubberized outside,
but it's hard as fuck around it.
And the compression shorts keep the glut,
the,
the a cup right over your junk.
And you could take full blast shots and you're not going to feel good.
But it feels way better than anything else I've ever used.
Yeah,
I've,
I've had the same fight.
I got my,
my Ipod,
I got a groin shot that splintered my cup.
It's splintered my cup.
And,
and uh,
I had a little cut,
a little cut from it.
I got kicking the pubic area,
but it was,
it was brutal and I hated,
hated that.
And then I to do,
to go to steel cups,
which it's got this in it.
Well,
the Steel Cup is,
I think probably one of the best,
that tie steel cup.
See that's,
that's their design.
It's a very good design of a cop,
but there's nothing too extraordinary about it.
But what's,
what's really interesting is the way it fits into the compression shorts,
the,
and this,
they,
they're constantly redesigning it.
They just had a new updated design.
It just sent me a couple of weeks ago.
But um,
I had a one incident in Jujitsu where I wasn't wearing a cup and I had a lot of
boy you,
um,
and uh,
since then I went to cups.
But a lot of guys say that the Steel Tie Cup is one of the best,
uh,
solutions too.
Cause you could tie that fucker up tight.
It feels super uncomfortable.
You know when it goes up your asshole area and the g string style.
But when it's tied in like really fucking tied in,
that's one of the best ways to uh,
to protect yourself too.
But they,
they'll,
they outlawed steel cups in Jujitsu matches.
Whoa.
Oh yeah.
Cause stuff like Frank Mir,
right,
with a breaking that up.
Yeah,
we'll the leverage you,
I mean it becomes like this insane fulcrum point because it's literally steal
and when that steel is pressed against your pelvis,
I mean that's like this crazy lever.
And if you get an arm there,
you know,
it's,
it's really unfair.
It's an unfair lever that doesn't exist in nature.
It's like the opposite of what nature gives you.
Like I've had a lot of people,
like you teach them how to do an Armbar,
like ah,
it hurts my balls.
Like,
yeah,
you got to get used to that.
Like an Armbar will probably hurt your balls,
but if you weren't a steel cup,
it hurts them way more than it hurts.
You popped a Tim Sylvia,
his arm and the forearm.
Right?
Well,
it's just something like,
certainly Frank Mir Yank and we'll for sure know.
And he's an incredible martial artist.
He's a Stud Jujitsu guy.
The best guys ever.
Whenever you can get into Gira and do that to him,
break his fucking arm.
Yeah.
That's,
and that's why he's the only guy in the UFC heavyweight division that's broken
to people's bones with submissions.
Wow.
You know,
I mean,
Frank Mir will go down in history is one of the greatest submission guys ever.
For sure.
The Times of grapple with them,
I was like,
wow,
he's amazing.
He's a stud.
He's a guy,
he's got a lot of fucking miles,
man.
He's,
he's fought a lot of fucking hard fights.
But um,
those,
uh,
those steel cups,
like you can't wear them anymore in Jujitsu matches.
So I mean,
I wonder how long before people recognize that in MMA and say,
cause right now you could get away with wearing a steel cup,
but like you ever had someone mount you and they have a steel cup on and like
compress your on your sternum.
It's brutal.
Yeah.
Those are dangerous man.
That in that way.
Well,
Hey,
amen.
Thank you for this one.
And I'm excited.
I'm excited to give it a give it a whirl.
Yeah,
those guys are pretty dedicated man.
This diamond and I shouldn't say pretty,
they're very dedicated.
There's diamond MMA guys.
They've done a lot of,
they're constantly redesigning that thing too,
but I think that's an issue.
Like there's guys who were like the standard jock strap with like the little
silly cup inside of it.
That's just fine if you're playing softball,
you know.
But God dammit,
when you're getting kicked the we really need like a,
a better,
a better design would come to my come to that.
Definitely me.
And Yeah.
Thank you so much for this.
And I also wanted to thank you man coming in here because the village of the
Bofi is the village that you guys sponsored and um,
they got a water.
Well,
so I'm just thankful you're giving me this.
You sponsored my family getting water.
We even had,
I mean if it's okay,
I could show you a picture.
Yeah,
please have.
This is kind of the drilling process right here.
Is that,
is that something you brought over there?
Yeah,
well the,
the tripod legs we bought in Uganda and then we,
we hold him over.
Um,
so that's,
that's our drillers.
They get ready,
they put it on that tripod.
This is us getting ready in Bobo fee to put the,
uh,
the pump down.
Um,
and so that,
those bricks in that circular,
it's a,
the cement well pad that we're getting ready to do.
But first we got to put the PVC down and put the pump.
How do you find where to drill?
Do you get one of those dudes that has chicken bone thing?
Cause that shit work?
No,
I,
I'm not sure if that works but,
but there's,
there's uh,
some expensive equipment that you can get,
but we,
we really there for the,
for the things that they're going to do and where they are in the rain forest,
there's water there,
there's clean water's just under your feet.
You got to get to it.
And so most people don't know how to get to it.
So we show them how to get down there to it.
And so it's once it's below six meters or 20 feet,
um,
the water force system,
uh,
it has been approved by us,
a USAID and the UN and all these places saying it's just as safe as,
as a lot of mechanic,
mechanic,
mechanicalized rigs.
And so what they do is they drill it down there.
And,
um,
once you get to a certain depth,
you can put a cement,
um,
cement pad that protects it at the top.
But you also put like a clay sanitary seal up from,
from six meters and above.
And then that makes it hard place.
Sanitary seal,
clean,
sanitary seal.
Do you guys make that or does it something you purchased?
Like how does it work?
Can purchase it.
Um,
did you guys make it?
What we would do is we'd go find it from a heel falling on a tee shirt.
There we go.
Yeah.
So that helped me out to over there.
So you,
you,
you helped out a lot over there.
Um,
but with the sanitary seal does is one meter of clay.
It can take a hundred years for,
for water to get through a one layer,
um,
impermeable,
impermeable clay.
And so if you can put that down there,
then it takes a long time.
So any,
any ground contaminants that are trying to pass through that first you have the
cement pad that we put on and then you have the clay sanitary seal beyond that,
and then it's,
it's not going to let the,
the ground contaminants and other kinds of waterborne disease get down in door
are clean aquifer.
So we find we tried to find a,
a good aquifer that's going to keep refilling.
Um,
that's,
that's fresh water,
clean water,
we test it,
all that.
And um,
did you have failed wells?
We tried to make some,
yeah,
we did.
We,
we,
the first,
probably seven or eight we failed because I had like a short training here.
Then they also sent over a guy that had,
had done 28 water wells in Congo and I was like,
great.
He's Congolese guy all the way across the country.
And we flew him out and he had,
he was 28 for 28.
He had never failed a well.
And then we got out there and we had seven in a row that we failed.
And so,
um,
so when you say failed,
like it didn't give you any water or as Badwater well,
I guess,
sorry,
what we should,
what I should have said,
it was seven holes fail.
And so what we're doing is we're looking for the water and sometimes you're,
you're digging and you come across a layer of,
of granite or a layer of our problem with sandstone.
What happened was we'd have these clay are these um,
these augers that have like these clause on it and we'd pull out scoop after
scoop after scoop and a foot at a time and sometimes get to like a sandstone
layer.
And if you get to that,
it's hard to advance through.
And so a lot of times you do need a machine that helps you get through that.
And so water four has been helping us with that.
And so normally under that sandstone layer,
there's,
there's fresh,
like a very good powerful aquifer that's going to give to probably be careful
about ruining your equipment on these.
We didn't want to waste our,
our tool.
So we would do is we'd,
we'd pick up and we move cause we can't make those tools yet in Congo.
So we're bringing them from the states and it's high quality stuff.
Um,
hopefully one day we do have a metal shop there that we can start trying to
produce things that we'll,
we'll just blast through,
you know,
softer layers.
And so you're doing this not just in the,
the pygmy villages,
but in also these neighboring villages to,
to try to help these people out so that they don't get angry at the pygmies are
having this stuff.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So how many of these wells have you guys?
15.
Wow.
15 water wells.
There's,
each one of them is serving hundreds of people.
This is both.
This is the GRE.
Uh,
well this is the Joe Rogan experience water.
Well that's so cool.
Or dancing around at cow happy.
Those people that's actually saying,
Gee,
on my shoulders,
on that other picture,
the hunter killed those two things.
That's so cool.
See when my shoulders,
if you go down,
this is a,
the chief's wife.
And uh,
she took one of our well jewelers sunglasses and she's a,
she was a second one to punk and uh,
so she loved it.
So then one more thing that's on top of that blue metal is that metal.
What is that thing that we're looking at that's pouring into the bucket?
Um,
the blue is actually just a,
a bucket that's holding our cement.
So it's like we use it as a form so we could pour the cement inside of it that
protects the,
the,
the pipes that are coming up from deep in the ground.
And the pump is a hand unit.
Is that how it works?
Yeah,
it's,
it's basically like a t handle.
And you,
you grabbed each side,
he pull up,
pull it down and pull up,
pumped down an old school cartoon dynamite things.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And every time you go down it sprays out,
I dunno,
maybe 10 ounces of water.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
So what is the quality of life change for these people now that they have this
clean water?
I mean,
it must be amazing.
Yeah.
They,
they've,
they've never,
uh,
seen clean water before.
They've never tasted it except for maybe rainwater,
but they don't have a way to collect it.
So it's like them going out and,
and uh,
if you go to the folder saying Badwater how often does it wrong?
The rains,
it rains quite often,
but they don't,
they don't collect the water.
It's easier for me to go to where the water sat,
where the creeks or streams that rose to get their,
their water there.
It seems like that would be an awesome supplement as well.
So that's the water that they usually get.
Yeah,
that,
that actually isn't,
that's actually a pretty good one.
But I thought it was cool here it was.
She was using the leaf as a funnel,
but she would scoop it and pour it into the,
into the container.
But yeah,
that's completely dirty contaminated.
That's where the,
the antelopes and other animals are going to get water and then they,
you know,
yeah,
absolutely man.
Guardia something that people get from gophers and shit and all these different
animal beavers.
I had typhoid while I was there.
What is typhoid like?
Um,
it's,
it's brutal,
but I had it at the same time.
That's why they misdiagnosed me with the malaria.
They thought that I had typhoid because I,
it was,
I had,
I had gotten typhoid but like a small amount of it.
And then,
um,
so they started treating me for typhoid and,
but it was,
so since it was mixed with malaria,
I don't know if,
if that was why malaria was so,
so brutal.
I mean,
I got it from two different sources.
Obviously had dirty,
dirty water or someone cooked with dirty water,
um,
and,
and adjusted the typhoid fever.
Then,
um,
so cooking with dirty water,
even if you boil the water,
it's still,
uh,
he's still get some of those illnesses that you,
you can't,
if you don't cook it correctly,
right.
If you don't get it really,
really hot.
And sometimes out here you're just cooking over a fire and just sticks and you
put on a,
a bowl over it and it's,
uh,
it's,
it has to get to that boiling point and stuff.
And if they don't cook it right or if they add some water to it,
you know,
a little later to add some more,
you can still get sick from that.
Did they have metal pots and pans and stainless steel or cast iron?
Like what are they cooking in?
Yeah,
a lot of times they do get,
um,
the,
well they would make a tripod.
I wonder if that's,
um,
in the folder they would make a tripod to smoke the meat.
Um,
and so they would just use wood in leafs to,
to cook the meat.
But yeah.
Would get the bargain or get the scraps from their,
either their slave masters as someone who went and worked for,
they would,
uh,
negotiate and bargain Labor to get some kind of potluck that's discarded and
yeah,
right there.
That's great.
That's,
that's uh,
but both the village,
the Jerry village and um,
and that's Kinda how they cook it so that when I think we brought with us
though,
and they just cooked it over the fire,
that one we got real hot.
And normally they don't,
they don't waste wood man.
They don't,
uh,
they just put an x where a cross of a,
of wood and they just push it in from the sides.
And so basically it's just smoldering.
There's no real flame.
And so that's how they cook.
It's not even on,
on a real hot flame.
Wow.
It's so much we take for granted and civilization those heights.
Ah,
maybe you killed to the folder with my wife.
Um,
he'll show some of the size of the pygmies and then also the huts.
But um,
it's,
it's crazy how they're living in this guys,
but John G,
but that behind them is,
uh,
is one of our huts that were staying in,
um,
so their huts,
you know,
chest,
chest height us.
Um,
and then living there.
It's crazy.
There's,
there's all sorts of stuff that come in there.
Spiders,
snakes,
um,
uh,
love those too.
A lot of poisonous stuff,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
A crazy story right here in this village was,
was a spider actually.
Uh,
Emily had gone in there and this is,
by the way,
this is her first ever camping trip.
Her first ever time camping.
She went hard.
That's how you go harder.
I don't know if they were camping in the Congo.
Wow.
Maybe there's another picture of a hut.
Her and I,
but it's,
it's crazy because,
yeah,
right there.
Um,
the rain had beat us there.
So I'm going from the roadside to getting to the actual village can take over an
hour.
Um,
we can take an hour and a half hiking.
And so rain had moved in and it just drenched us on her first night ever
camping.
And then,
uh,
and there was roaches.
Well,
it stopped raining and then you're,
you're thinking that it's raining,
but it's actually that sprinkling,
but it's actually the legs of the roaches running on the leafs that freaked her
out.
Um,
and she had to get up and leave.
And,
uh,
I understood,
you know,
I walked her out.
It's going to be okay.
She's like,
because one of the roaches had fallen on her neck and she,
that's when she kind of lost it.
And I don't know if I can do this,
but,
but after that,
she embraced it and really fell in love with the people.
Um,
and then there was another crazy story with this gigantic spider,
or at least to me when you'll know why I thought it was gigantic in a minute,
but,
uh,
it was,
it was on her.
What we'd do is we put up a little tent,
almost like a mosquito net tent inside of the huts so that she could be
protected from all the mosquitoes and stuff like that.
But Ben and I would sleep next to that and we,
we didn't have a mosquito net over us.
And all of a sudden she saw this gigantic spider crawling on the Mesh and she
freaked out and called for me.
And then it jumped.
It's like this tranche Isla kind of spider and it jumped onto the leafs and
that's the wall.
It's just leaves and sticks.
Um,
and so I grabbed a flip flops trying to kill this tranche,
Ila.
And whenever,
whenever I finally started to hit at it,
it slipped right behind one of the leafs and disappeared.
And she's like,
you didn't kill it.
And I'm like,
ah,
yeah,
I think I did.
And Ben,
Ben's like,
I killed.
Yeah,
he killed it.
He killed it.
And she's like,
I want to see a lag of body something.
I want to see its guts.
And,
um,
so anyways,
right after that too,
there's two chicken sleeping beside her,
her tent in the wall.
She's like,
get these chickens out of here.
So I grabbed them,
got to know,
but then the next day we woke up and she woke up before me and she was outside.
The women were kind of painting,
doing this awesome paintings on a bark cloth.
So it's cloth that is actually just bark.
And so they're out there painting.
It's bark cloth lying.
What do you mean by clot?
They make like a coffee.
Used to be,
there used to be clothing that they would wear like in traditional ceremonies,
but it'd be cloth that they are bark that they would beat down and it would kind
of be like these fibers that would stick together and it actually be like a,
a bark cloth.
Uh,
you know,
I'll,
I'll have Emily bring you some of it.
She's coming out here and we got your knife.
Um,
because they can bang down these knives into a,
or banged down these nails into knives.
Super wicked looking and sharp,
but they can make nails into knives.
And so we got you one of those.
And uh,
and it's,
it's nuts.
The things that could get his nails,
if they can turn them into a knife there,
they're normally pretty big,
like from like the lumber guys and stuff,
whatever they're doing,
if they're building a,
uh,
ladders and things like that.
Um,
and so they,
they can do everything.
And so she was out there watching them paint on this bark cloth.
I think if you just Google bark cloth,
they'll show it to.
But,
um,
uh,
and then I step out of the hut and Ben standing there and when Ben standing
there,
he looks at me and uh,
and all of a sudden he goes,
don't move.
And I said,
my eyes got big.
why?
And whenever.
I said,
why?
All of a sudden I saw that big spider from the night before that Transla it was
in my,
at the time,
gigantic chest length beard and its legs are just coming up right on my face
and,
and then literally just slaps you in the fall.
My Gosh,
it's so hard.
Just smacked me.
And,
and the,
the,
the spider fell and,
um,
Emily starts turning around and been steps on top of the trench line cause he
doesn't want to freak her out.
She's like,
what just happened?
I said,
oh,
nothing.
Nothing happened.
She's like,
what's going on?
And Ben Still,
you know,
moving his foot back and forth,
squashing the thing,
killing it,
making sure it's dead.
But,
um,
there's crazy stuff out there.
Like I've,
I've been able to pull out,
I think Emily and I counted five times in one night that I pulled these little
roaches out of my beard because I guess they think it's like a nest or something
like that,
that he grown that crazy beard out there,
man.
Well,
I didn't take any beard trimmers with the or anything like that,
but also I want to see how long it would get in a year.
And,
and it's kind of an icebreaker for me.
It's Kinda,
it's kinda funny or crazy,
but for me,
um,
they,
they've never seen something like it.
I,
I look like an animal to them a lot of times walking through.
They had these jokes that,
um,
I wouldn't want to,
wouldn't want to come across him and a dark forest,
you know,
and I'm a dark in a dark path and,
uh,
I've come into the village actually,
but both of you,
that one,
whenever I first walked in,
people grab their kids,
jumped in their huts or,
or,
or literally just booked it and disappeared through the forest because they
didn't never seen anything like you before.
They never seen a white dude.
I'm never seen someone with light skin and,
um,
white dudes exist.
I'm sure.
I'm sure there they did.
Um,
but then never seen it.
Never heard of it.
They've heard stories.
I mean,
they've been told at times,
it's almost like sometimes a white guys or the boogeyman or something where,
um,
you know,
if,
if you don't behave,
a white man's going to come get you or come eat you.
Cause I've heard that before.
Yeah.
And so for me to go in there,
they're,
they're really a timid or scared at first until,
um,
until I develop a relationship with them.
And,
and as goofy as it is,
my hair on my head,
my Harry Harry,
enormously hairy arms and beard and long hair.
It can be an icebreaker so we can first scare them.
Then it can be an icebreaker and then it can be a kind of entertainment for
them.
They braid my hair,
they played with my beard all that.
Well,
there's some great videos of you that have gone online and people who actually
tweeted to me,
not even knowing that I know you have them seeing you for the first time.
Oh,
pygmies touching you and touching your beard and senior white skin for the first
time.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Some of the rumors that happened to his,
uh,
there was a neighboring village and he,
he had sprinted from Bofi back to Baja and um,
like he was visiting there,
got terrified,
ran away and basically said that there was a,
a big white ape that had walked into the village.
And,
uh,
and basically I was a great white Sasquatch or vanilla gorilla and,
and he,
it made them terrified.
And so then he found out that we had been there.
We'd gotten them land,
we'd dug a,
well,
we started farming yams and potatoes and beans and corn now there.
And so it's,
uh,
it's been,
it's been pretty funny.
Another,
another thing,
it was a,
one of the slave master villages,
um,
had said that I came to,
uh,
to leave Mike concept was going on about someone else talking.
My Real,
my real a reason of being there was that because I would go and I would walk
with them to,
to the dirty water source.
If you get pulled up the Badwater,
I would carry it with them.
Um,
just to experience how long that they would have to walk.
Sometimes they were walking five miles,
five miles,
um,
with dirty water,
dirty water to come back and cook with and give their kids and drink and bathe
in those,
those,
uh,
I think our 20 or 40 liters or something like that.
But they're,
they're like 30,
40 pounds man.
And in my neck just doing that with them,
we get so incredibly sore in these,
I mean,
those are,
are grown women next to me and they're,
they're walking sometimes with two of them.
Um,
sometimes they're walking with two of those and,
or,
uh,
one about half that size,
but the,
the other people from the other tribes that are bigger and stronger,
they're walking with one on top of their head and one over there back.
And it's just crazy.
And,
and,
and women,
those villages that said,
what I really come there to do was study,
um,
studied their,
their streams,
their creeks.
And then I left behind,
uh,
my,
my half fish,
half woman,
uh,
at and station.
I'm at each,
each little creek in each little stream that I was going and investigating.
So,
so basically they're saying that I had,
I had brought in Mermaids to leave,
to leave at every,
every village.
And I'm like,
where did that come from?
Like,
where did you guys think I'm coming up with a,
a mermaid to come bring in and leave here?
And uh,
they didn't say it was evil or anything,
but they said I was bringing mermaids.
It's so strange.
It's like you are,
you know,
you're living in the 21st century,
but it's almost like you're,
you're going into this land that hasn't changed much in thousands of years and
they still have the same sort of like mythologies and folklore that you'd expect
from people that lived before education,
before the Internet,
before even before books.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's like you're going back in time because people don't have cell phones.
A lot of times we would,
I would do is,
yeah,
I would take,
um,
we take pictures together,
but then I'd come in and I would go into town and I brought with me.
Um,
it's called,
uh,
I think it's called a selfie.
It's like a little canon printer and a,
I could print off photos that I took.
So I'd go back and them seeing themselves on my,
my camera for the first time.
Some of this is their first time seeing themselves.
Well,
besides being in there like a reflection of water or,
I mean,
they don't have mirrors.
Whoa.
You don't have cameras don't have any of that.
So how did they see themselves besides their reflection?
And so,
but what we would do is,
I mean there's been other people that have come into some of the villages and
take pictures and they leave and then they never get to see them.
Um,
but we would go print them and we come back and we'd give them family photos.
We'd give them like a family portrait and uh,
and so,
but we would either put it in like almost a ziplock bag or,
or,
or kind of do one time we did like this laminate kind of stuff on it because in
their living conditions,
in their huts with the rain coming through it with their,
their ground sometimes turning to mud that they're sleeping on.
Um,
you know,
we wanted to protect the pictures that we're giving them.
But just something like that,
it's a,
it's a small gift to us,
but to them it just blows their mind that you can take a picture of them a
moment in time.
You can go print it and then you can give it back to them and now they can have
it for forever if they keep it,
keep it right.
That's incredible man.
Is there any superstition involved in photographs like you heard with like the
native Americans?
No,
not,
not there now in other places,
like populated areas and Congo and you'd gone in Rwanda,
um,
anywhere that there's been conflict that then brings in a lot of reporters and,
and,
and other people,
like they come and they take pictures and the locals will say,
oh,
they're coming and taking our pictures and then they're there.
They're going and making money off of us.
We don't get to see those pictures,
anything like that.
So you have to be like,
I'm not going around like a tourist and taking pictures.
Um,
when I get into the village,
you know,
sometimes I pull it out for entertainment and,
and,
and show them themselves where they can,
you know,
on the iPhone where you can actually see yourself on the screen at that time.
And their eyes just light up and it's like a,
it's like a mirror,
but it's,
you know,
it's,
it's on a screen and so it's crazy for him.
That is so cool man.
Because what an amazing journey you've been on,
man.
I mean just,
I know Loretta Hunt Who's sitting over here to our right to your right,
who you've written a bunch of books,
Loretta and she's writing a book about you right now.
I,
I want to read that book man.
Cause I think it's really fascinating,
but I think a documentary is really what we need to see to like someone needs to
get out of some bad mother fuckers to go with a camera crew to the Congo to,
yeah.
Well we did something for water four and it's,
it's on Vimeo.
Um,
but it's called a freedom in the Congo in a,
it's a very,
very well done.
Seven minute documentary of kind of the work we were doing.
Um,
so yeah,
it's called freedom in the Congo on Vimeo.
And the,
what was so cool is this guy that came to film it,
his name's Derek Watson and he's done stuff for national geographic and PBS and
he's done like full documentaries and,
and,
and got a woman named sister Rosemary.
Those helping girls that were abducted by the LRA and,
and made quote unquote wives of them.
But really they're just sex slaves.
She would help them out in his documentary,
got hurt and uh,
and Times Mat Time magazine's top 100 people.
But um,
but anyways,
he snuck in a a Gopro drone.
Here it is right here.
So it's uh,
what the forest like slacks.
Yeah.
And that's what I thought,
you know,
living in my American bubble,
there's no slaves today.
You got rid of that in the 18 hundreds slavery in today's age.
Why,
why should it exist?
My problem when I say my
money,
I see this is all subtitled for folks that are just listening to this freedom in
the Congo,
check it out on Vimeo slave masters and come up to me and say,
raise your doing with my animals.
What are you here doing with my property?
I own these people.
Be A,
they
just don't get to stay in two bananas.
Need to be given
something small so that they can come back and work the next day so that they're
hungry enough that they have to come back and work the next day.
Yeah,
let's leave this for people to watch the full thing.
So they don't,
yeah.
One thing on that that we're going to edit,
um,
just just to,
to to know is it says on there,
it says band Bantu on it and,
and yeah,
they are some of the,
the,
the slave masters there.
Um,
it's the banter and the pygmies,
but really it's the,
the Mokpala.
Um,
and it's,
it's basically the,
the non pygmies in the region that the pygmies live.
So I never,
we don't want to villainize a certain people group.
We,
again,
we want to work with both sides and we want to be,
we want to add to each.
We don't want to take away,
we don't want to,
we don't want to hurt them in the process,
but we want to educate them that,
hey,
there's were both equals and how can we do this and the best way possible.
So we're changing that just so that there's no like,
um,
nothing,
nothing seemed like we're trying to,
to,
to point them out because they're the biggest people group in,
uh,
in all of Africa.
And they're there,
most of them live where there aren't even pygmies.
But where there are pygmies,
most of them,
most of the time the pygmies are being enslaved to these guys.
Know these,
these pygmy folks.
Do they know that you,
uh,
fought in the UFC?
Did they understand what the UFC is?
I'm trying to explain it.
They,
they,
they kind of like wondering how can that be a job?
Cause they've only seen physical conflict.
Um,
whenever there's a real dispute,
you know,
and there's,
there's not really martial arts there.
Um,
but,
but they,
they do kind of wrestle around some.
And,
um,
but it,
it's gotten me out of,
out of trouble before,
um,
in the Congo.
I had a Topps card and uh,
and I just kept it with me on me and I tried to show him and it was me just
blossoming guy hit him in the chin and it was a anyways,
um,
yeah,
they're being real corrupt and everything.
And I showed him it and ended up signing and just giving it to them.
They let us go and instead of paying any money,
I'm a baseball card or MMA version of the basement.
Well,
what they're going to try to still a,
well Dzielawa he's my grandfather.
He gave me a,
uh,
a pygmy bow and arrow,
a bunch of arrows in a bow.
And this,
this guy was just saying,
um,
that it was illegal for me to have it.
That,
and I'm like,
it's a gift.
He's like,
no,
no.
You came here to come and take our artifacts back to your country and make
thousands of dollars and if you're going to go make those thousands of dollars
and you have to give me hundreds of dollars,
I'm like,
that's not gonna happen.
It's not going to happen.
And so he's like trying to pull it out of my hand.
I said,
what if I give you this?
And just gave him the,
gave him the UFC Dobbs card and talk to them and played around with them.
And you know,
if you just,
sometimes when they're asking you to give them something,
Matt actually taught it to me,
the guy in the video,
um,
from water for he,
if they,
if they ask for you to give them something,
somebody just got to give them anything and they'll let you go.
It can be a bottle of water that can be,
um,
a passion.
Fruit can be a banana.
Um,
one time it was a,
it was a guy said,
you've got to give me something or I'm not going to let you go.
So just wrap them up in a big bear hug afterwards.
I said,
there,
I gave you a hug.
And uh,
he was,
he was laughing,
you know,
and,
and in between us,
you know,
that he's got,
he's got a machine gun and so we're,
whoa.
And so we're bear hugged to do with a machine gun.
Well,
he wasn't holding onto it and like pointing it at me or anything.
They just always have them around them.
That's still in.
Matt had done that,
that basically that same thing.
Um,
and I think Togo,
um,
where,
where he was doing water wells all,
all throughout there,
he's done hundreds there.
Um,
but yeah,
it's just sometimes you got to find a way to,
to,
to make them laugh or to make them like you were to,
to try to find a way to,
to,
to get the job done.
Did they speak English when you're communicating with these people?
Um,
some of them are and some of them are pretty educated.
It's crazy how I think it's harder for us in our culture to learn languages
because we don't grow up learning several languages at once.
But they're,
they're growing up learning four,
five,
six languages at one time.
And so some of them,
yeah,
they speak English very fluently.
And are they learning this from a school?
Are they learning this from school or a lot of times the military are learning
it from,
um,
their,
their jobs,
their work.
If there's humanitarian organizations that,
that are,
are speaking English and,
and different things like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
What is the end game for you here?
I mean,
you're,
you're obviously improving their lives dramatically by creating these wells and
bringing the medicine.
Well,
what do you eventually hope to do?
that's a,
that's a big question,
but I'll,
I'll try to simplify it.
I just want them to know that they're loved,
um,
that,
they're not forgotten.
Um,
and that,
um,
this is a lifelong thing for me.
There's no way.
I mean,
it doesn't matter what's going on.
I'm going to be going there in my entire life and what I,
what I hope is just to add,
add to their life.
Like for me,
whenever I sit back and I say,
okay,
what does a perfect world looked like?
Um,
and,
and how can I try to,
to take action to see that,
that the good comes into the world instead of the bad.
So the evil,
so the,
the,
the kids dying of,
of,
of dirty water,
you know,
what can I do as a person too,
to see that that is alleviated at least a little bit,
even just for one person if I can do that.
And so for me and my,
my,
my pygmy family,
like I don't want to see that same kind of suffering them.
We've actually seen him set free now and we've seen them get clean water and
seeing them have food and that's hopefully just the beginning of,
of different things that will be a lifelong way to,
to sustain them and in the people in that region.
When,
when you're there and you,
you,
you hang out with these people,
especially when they know that you've done,
you know,
the UFC and they,
they understand that you like participate in professional conflict as it were.
Do you teach them things?
Do you ever like have a class there?
I've,
I've shown a few of them,
uh,
about maybe 10 or 15 of the men one time.
Just some little,
little wrestling.
I was teaching them a,
an arm drag,
um,
just because I didn't want people falling down and getting hurt or something
like that.
So seeing some in the arm drag throw by,
um,
a little bit of a double leg,
but how to set them down easy.
Um,
so it's fun.
And then they really grabbed onto it,
um,
in guiding bolt by Wanda,
by wanting to just,
he loved it and he would go around and he would be grabbing on to everybody.
I'm dragging him the arm dragging up,
jumping on their back and teach them how to take the back.
Yeah.
From [inaudible] arm,
Jackson road by,
from a throw by,
not,
not on the ground grappling,
but I would,
uh,
yeah,
he would get behind them and that was just his natural reaction was to be a
spider monkey.
Just jump on their back.
I'm Marcello Garcia style back on them.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
What about striking?
Do you teach may striking?
No,
I haven't done that man.
I think,
I think for me now,
it hasn't been a big thing showing them Marshall,
I had some my big passion I'd love for him too,
but it's just kind of hard being in the jungle and the forest.
There's trees everywhere.
There's stumps everywhere.
There's,
it's hard to get a,
a nice space to,
to grapple.
Yeah.
I would imagine that would be,
especially for take downs,
right?
Yeah.
Fall down.
Landed a log up your ass when you are planning.
I mean if you,
if you committed to this plan of fighting again or was it still something that
you have in your head?
Haven't having to un like announced it or formally made a plan with anybody yet.
But,
um,
for me,
my family,
my wife and in the teeth take down,
guys know that I'm gonna make a real,
real,
real stab at it.
So you'd definitely going to do it.
I'm going to do it.
So when you do that,
how much time will you spend here and how much time we spend there?
And how much time do you spend here and there?
Right now?
Yeah.
Well,
I've been going since 2011 and,
um,
I've taken,
you know,
month long trips there until this last one,
which was a one year trip.
Um,
and if I go back into fighting,
it would only allow me to probably to go there one,
two or Max three times a year,
um,
for anywhere from two to four weeks at a time.
So I would love to train hard to fight hard.
I'll never have,
I know one thing's for sure.
I'll never have more motivation to be the dude to go in there to get my hand
raised,
not just for me but,
but,
but for starting my family with my wife,
but also for the family there in Congo.
That more's going to be added to,
to them into,
to,
to alleviate what's going on there.
Now will you released by the UFC or did you just stop fighting?
Like what,
what happened?
Yeah,
I was released and then I fought and I won three fights and that stepped away.
Um,
I was,
I,
I'm sure there was,
uh,
an open door to go back organization.
Did you want win three fights with a ring of fire?
Okay.
Um,
so you were in Denver and then,
and then I fought in Vegas once for another promotion.
Thought uh,
do the,
I think it was six and now at the time and uh,
and stopped him.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
for me though,
I know that it would be a,
it wouldn't be a step right back into that level of the UFC.
Right.
Not right away.
I'd have to work my way back up to that.
Um,
but you know what though,
if the right opponent and stuff like that comes along,
but,
but for me,
I,
I want to train hard but smart,
be strategic about the matchups.
Um,
I mean me,
I'm,
I'm a competitor.
Whenever I,
I was wrestling at Kenny Monday as my high school coach,
Olympic gold medalist,
can Kendall cross Olympic gold medalist,
then I went to Olympic training center.
So something,
I think if you ask Brendan or anyone that's trained with me,
they'll,
they'll say that I'm a competitor and then my harder or spirit is a spirit of a
fighter harness.
Mondays at team take down.
That's something that is,
is,
you know,
is a light bulb was amazed that they let him go with the black zillion.
So I was like,
are you crazy?
What a wealth of knowledge that guy has.
And it comes to,
I mean,
I guess it was a personality conflict or something like that,
but man,
what a great coach.
That guy is in a great wrestler.
Yeah.
With me high school.
And then ever since then,
and then even now,
whenever I stepped away,
he fully 100% supported everything and said that,
uh,
he loves what I'm doing,
but,
but what's so great about coach monies,
he really will invest into people in and really teach them slick stuff that
you're not going to find from a,
from a high school or college program.
Like this is a Olympic level stuff that,
that's coming from all over the world and it's the little things that matter.
And so he's able to teach us those things and he's great man.
Yeah.
I thought he was a great addition to a team take down.
I saw him when he was training and working with Johny Hendricks and the rematch
with Robbie Lawler.
What's going on right now with Johny Hendricks?
So you uh,
you training with him,
you,
you're there with him and I've watched him train.
I mean I haven't really stepped in there yet.
I think for me right now,
I mean I'm,
I'm out of shape,
I'm out of shape and,
and I want to come back and my problem was that I would,
I would,
uh,
I would come back too soon and then a injuries would happen.
So I'm going to get my core and all that back before I step in there with those
guys.
What do you weigh right now to 82 82 80 right now.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so I'll have to get back down.
I'll probably be around two 55 round fight time to 50.
Um,
that's,
that's me coming back from,
from Congo,
having no food coming back and have him all the food.
It might've screaming.
Cue Baby.
Yeah.
You live in Dallas?
Oh yeah.
My grandpa owns a,
a several barbecue restaurants have Texas barbecue is something special,
man.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's a,
you're living in an incredible life man.
You know,
I think it'd be really fascinating if you did come back and what a story that
would be and how,
I mean it would generate an incredible amount of press and an incredible amount
of attention towards what you're trying to do in the Congo.
Well,
that,
that's,
I'm mean,
that's humbling to hear because I mean,
I respect your opinion so much of being in the fight game for so long.
Um,
I,
I want to be realistic about it and say like right now I'm,
I'm not looking at the,
the world champion level,
you know,
I'm not aiming at that right now,
but,
but that could be a future goal once I get back into it,
get,
get in shape and really start,
start,
start just knocking some dudes down.
Do you know how crazy it would be if you got to the point where you're fighting
for the title?
Do you know how bananas that would be?
That would be nuts.
What mean you want to talk about the most incredible PR campaign ever?
I mean,
you want to talk about some someone that you could really get behind and root
for Jesus Christ.
You'd have the whole world rooting for you.
God Damn Rocky moving.
I'm getting goosebumps.
Well,
it'd be crazy,
man.
Yeah.
If you could really get into like top shape.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
I would love that.
That would be the perfect world.
That's the thing.
Like I feel like I feel like in my heart that that's one of my deepest desires
is to fight and contend for the highest possible good in every circumstance.
Like it doesn't matter if it's there or here,
whatever it is.
Whenever I'm meeting somebody like like what can I do to,
to,
to add to the lives of another and if I can do that through fighting something
that I'm very passionate about.
I mean I think,
yeah,
I mean it's humbling the,
that goes through my mind.
I try to be realistic,
try to,
but,
but at the same time,
I'm a big dreamer and I think that if,
if I could do,
I mean that would be obviously the,
the,
the cat's pajamas.
If I could,
if I could be the champion Pajama pants with,
imagine if you won the title.
I mean,
that would be unbelievable.
Obviously that's going to take some superhuman dedication to,
to hit that level at that level without it.
So,
um,
but yeah,
that,
that's,
that's what's so motivating about me getting back into it as I see a huge
opportunity to,
to,
to fulfill that first promise.
I gave him me and I was standing at the grave of Andy Bo,
and that held him in my hands and had had his blood on me and I had,
I had,
I had buried him.
And,
uh,
and it was so tough,
so hard.
And then one of the chiefs came to me and said,
nobody knows about what's happening to us.
Nobody knows about the suffering.
And he said,
I know you can't promise us water,
land,
any of that stuff,
but can you,
can you,
can you tell people,
can you at least,
you know,
give us a voice.
And so that's whenever I,
I made that promise.
And so me going back into fighting,
it'd be extremely emotional for me to get back into it,
to get back in shape,
to go back in there,
to,
to knock some dudes out there.
They're going to have to,
they're going to have to put me away.
Um,
really like really put me away for me not to,
to,
to do everything in my power to win that fight.
He's had a ridiculous jam.
That was like one of your biggest size huts.
You take a tremendous shot.
Is that always been the case?
I,
the people would always joke saying,
I have some fucking viking head.
Yeah,
we'll even a heavyweight.
My head's normally like twice the size and everyone else.
So it's an easy target,
but,
but it's,
but it,
but it takes a beating.
Was it a tough watching a fellow viking go down this weekend when he's tough,
was like him afterwards.
Like even with Anthony saying that,
you know,
he's crying.
I can't even celebrate.
That was tough.
Well,
he's so loved there man.
I mean,
that's a,
that he literally is carrying the entire country on his back there.
I mean,
there's a tremendous amount of pressure involved in that.
A tremendous amount of love too.
They,
they fucking love Gustafson me.
And they were cheering for him after he lost.
No,
but it's like in America,
I mean,
I don't want to shit on America,
but man,
when people lose in America,
everybody fucking clears out of the arena right away,
you know?
And nobody cleared out after he lost.
They stuck around and they wait.
I mean,
you're talking about an arena filled with 26,000 people to,
it's a long fucking commute.
It's zero degrees outside.
It's cold as fuck.
And they all stuck around and they were,
they were chanting out his name after he lost.
Wow.
I didn't know that.
I knew that it was,
it was a deafening silence when he lost.
I could just start crying.
If I started thinking about it,
I could have started crying.
Then,
you know,
watching him,
it was pretty intense,
but I was so blown away by rumble too.
It's like,
yeah,
it was just like this combination of,
I mean that's often how it is when you watch fights.
It's like there's a combination of moments like,
like I'm a big fan of John Jones,
but I'm also a big fan of Daniel Cormier.
I love Daniel.
I love both those guys as human beings as well as as fighters.
So after John Jones trounce Daniel like part of me was like,
man,
I feel sorry for Daniel,
but other part of me and was like,
God Damn Dan,
Jon Jones is a bad motherfucker.
It's like there's this weird sort of,
you know,
you,
you revel in the moment for the guy who won the also,
you got to look at like a guy like Gustafson and go,
wow,
it's,
it's hard.
Hard for him.
It's got to be hard.
It's really cool about hearing that about the Swedish fans though.
I mean,
that's,
that's a reason why I love the pride.
Who Was it?
The fans are so educated and they would sit there,
you know,
quiet and polite and,
and uh,
and then whenever they would appreciate even the moves of grappling,
you know,
passing,
full guard to half guard and they would,
they would,
they would clap,
you know,
that's,
that's something that here you,
and you're starting to see that more now.
You know,
people understand positions like a,
someone to move to a mount,
you'll hear like a big cheer or like throughout the audience are,
people understand.
But yeah,
Japan,
it's a very,
very different environment.
There's,
it's incredibly quiet while the fights are going on.
Yeah.
And then there's a cheer when there's some sort of a transition or someone does
something good.
Yeah.
And they also,
they don't put as much of an emphasis on winning as they do.
As much as you fought your hardest.
And there's always gonna be people that beat you.
Like you could,
you could train your hardest and you run into somebody who's just far better
than you.
And there's just nothing you can do about it.
That guy's always going to be,
you know,
there's certain guys like,
like perfect example,
Stephan Bonner,
when he fought Anderson Silva,
you can fight your hardest man.
You're not going to be an Anderson Silva.
You know,
you just,
you as he's better,
he's just better,
you know,
he's just,
he trains just as hard.
He's probably just as smart,
if not smarter,
knows way more can move way better snow.
But in Japan,
in Japan,
when a guy would fight like that,
they would still appreciate your warriors.
This was going to say,
it's like that Samurai kind of spirit,
you know,
and um,
America,
we just like [inaudible].
Yeah,
we like winners.
When you lose,
people will get on your fucking Facebook page.
So they'll get on your Twitter page.
I mean,
I've read some,
you know,
I don't want to call them fans,
just douche bags that torment people after the lose.
And I've read some of the tweets and it's just fucking appalling.
It's appalling that these anonymous shitheads who go on these guys pages after
they spent,
you know,
eight weeks plus camps every day preparing for this moment.
And then they get,
they get trounced and then people just go off on them and they make memes about
him and mock him.
And you know,
that's a very unfortunate aspect of our culture that,
that they put so much emphasis on,
on the winner only.
But it's,
on the other hand,
it's like that cruelty and that intense pressure.
It's also why the baddest motherfuckers come out of that culture.
It's like people that can withstand that.
And I mean it's,
there's a union,
the Yang and the Yin is harder.
And the Yang,
it's harder.
It's,
it's weird.
You know,
there's,
I don't think it's the right way to be.
I certainly don't think there's enough respect paid to the people that lose in,
in MMA,
in America.
I think I appreciate the Japanese version of it better.
I don't like when bonuses either.
I mean,
uh,
I don't know that the UFC probably doesn't like to hear this,
but I think,
I think a guy should be paid a certain amount to fight.
And I know the guys are going to fight.
They're fucking hardest.
I mean they're not,
they're not fighting harder because they get a win bonus.
They're trying to survive.
I mean you could say that,
I mean you could explain that more than anybody,
but you're trying to win.
It's a win bonus.
Like the fact that you can make 50% more if you win,
then you do.
If you lose,
like it's Kinda,
it's Kinda,
yeah,
it's Kinda crazy.
Cause once you get to a certain level at least yes.
You know,
once you get to a certain level,
I mean,
I don't think that it does make you fight harder afterwards.
It sucks more.
Yes.
It sucks because now you can't,
you can't pay the bills that you were hoping to and things like that.
Well Tyron Woodley had a really good statement recently.
We was talking about how people are always saying,
uh,
you know,
don't leave it in the hands of the judges.
He's like,
do you fucking think we're trying to move it in the hands of the judges,
you know,
they're fighting the best guys in the goddamn world.
There's,
it's like you do what you can do.
And if you do more than that,
like if you do something stupid or you do something illogical or you do
something reckless,
you can get knocked the fuck out.
I mean that,
that's,
you have to f I'm a big Fan of guys fighting intelligently,
you know?
And when,
when people fight intelligently,
sometimes it's not the most entertaining fight,
but that is the fight that you have to,
that's the way you have to perform in order to,
to use your skills to the best of your ability.
You know,
and people don't understand that.
And this idea that like they're trying to leave it in the hands of the judges.
I mean,
occasionally you'll see a guy fight safe,
you know,
you see a guy that goofy fight,
um,
or the goofy inning Nate Kore versus who was it where he's walked in?
Oh yeah,
you welcome download Starnes yeah,
I'm sure they wouldn't want to paid him the same amount.
I'm sure they were happy that they paid him 50% yes.
That's,
that's the worst example of all times.
And I don't know what was wrong with Caleb Starnes in that fight,
but yeah,
that's uh,
I mean,
those memes exist for that will haunt that dude forever,
you know?
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
But I think,
yeah,
once you get to a certain level and they're in,
and if you're a real competitor that does have the eye on the top prize,
then then you're going to fight your heart out every single time.
I'm glad Woodley said that.
That's a very important point.
That's,
I don't mind.
That's great.
Yeah.
I don't like that.
Leave it.
Don't leave it in the hands of the judges,
you know?
Oh,
you know,
it's just,
it's,
and then the,
the judge Stahnke too is a real issue.
Like in Boston,
there was a few retaught hall hall hard decisions where people just want what
and people just turned around and we'll looking at each other.
I love watching a decision when a decision is bad.
I always turn towards the crowd cause I like,
I like watching people look at each other like what the fuck?
Cause you'll see like head turns where people like turn to their friends.
Like what the fuck just happened?
How did the APP,
yeah,
there's some bad fucking judging man.
There's some really,
really bad judging and it didn't help that it was in Boston where the white guys
were getting the good judges,
the good call,
you know,
cause Boston where I'm from.
No,
exactly known for uh,
the least racist place on the planet.
You know?
Yeah.
I don't want to sound sexist at all,
but one of my fights on the,
oops,
whenever you say I don't want to,
sorry.
On,
on the ultimate fighter,
when I fought a big country,
um,
two of the three judges we had were,
were women and one had gray hair and the other had her two kids that were
running around running around at the,
the ultimate fighter like Jim.
And,
and so she was worried about her kids while we were warming up for the fight.
And then,
and then I'm not saying that affected the decision.
Um,
it could have gone a third round.
Uh,
I definitely believe that,
but,
but at the same time,
like it was just nuts to me that I'm like,
Whoa,
how are these,
the judges in Vegas?
Not that I mean,
but I think that judges should at least have had of trained or fought before.
We're really had to have gone through some,
some deep,
um,
training to become a judge.
You,
there's no way you understand it any other way?
I don't,
especially the ground game,
you know,
there's a judge,
I don't want to say his name,
but he told me that he was watching a fight once and there was a woman who was
also judging and the guy was going for a Kamora and the woman said,
what's he doing?
Oh my gosh.
She said to him,
what's he doing?
What's he doing?
Like,
God damn it.
See,
see,
for my fight it was nuts because I'm like this woman,
I don't know that she's ever,
I mean,
maybe she had really watched MMA and studied it,
but she's got gray hair.
It's not normally into to her,
you know,
element and then her time zone or whatever.
But uh,
but then also the other lady that brought her kids there,
I'm like,
do they know what these moves are that we're doing?
Like do they know the names of them?
Do they know the setups?
Do they know the diff defenses?
Do they know what's going on during the fight?
While that,
while that human chess match is going on,
do they know what the fighters are thinking?
Doing,
how,
how they're making it happen?
And if they don't,
they shouldn't be judging.
There's no way they should be judging.
I mean,
there's so many fans of MMA,
and I've said this many times,
I've even said this on broadcasts,
there's so many incredibly knowledgeable fans of MMA that if they held open
casting calls for new judges,
you would get incredibly qualified people who have either trained their whole
lives or competed multiple times that enjoy the sport,
love the sport like you,
if you decided to never like Ricardo Almeda,
he's a judge in New Jersey.
That's great.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
He judges in New Jersey Guy,
I would trust fucking without a doubt.
There were,
or even if it was a girl,
if it was one of the women that had fought for a shrine before,
push like,
uh,
a rose or Rhonda or someone like that.
Like I could trust their judgment.
Yeah.
And I think you should be like,
God,
you've got to have some grasp on your experience because grappling seems to be
the most confusing.
Seemed like if someone like is hitting the other guy more and the other guy gets
stunned,
it's Kinda obvious all that guy's winning the fight.
But if you're watching like say a guy who's like really slick on the ground,
like a,
you know,
fill in the blanks.
Some,
some,
some guy who's got a nasty guard and he's putting this guy and all sorts of bad
positions.
But the other guys on top,
like sometimes,
you know,
people,
uh,
like uh,
Charles Olivera preference example,
we fudge Jeremy Stephens.
I mean he was catching Jeremy Stevens and all kinds of shit,
but Jeremy's a beast and he kept falling out of it.
But from my money,
he's winning the exchanges.
I mean he,
he had like threatened with armbars,
he's threatening with all this sort of shit off of his back.
If you don't know what the fuck is going on and you're watching that,
I think if you got on top swimming,
exactly.
You might be inclined to think that.
And I think with a person who's trained you,
you,
you understand it way better.
And I just think it's unfair,
like it just deeply,
deeply,
deeply unfair for professional fighter who's taking eight weeks out of his life
and,
and just every morning and got up sore.
And did his road work and you know,
hitting the pads and sparring and doing constant drills and strength and
conditioning.
You're jumping over hurdles,
you doing all this fucking shit.
You want to puke blood you're throwing up.
And then some,
a whole who doesn't know shit about what they're talking about gives the other
person,
they just,
they just go left or right,
you know,
own,
pick this guy and it's a lot more than that eight weeks of training to that all
goes into it.
All of the stuff that ever came before it and all your heart,
all your soul and all that.
And then what is,
I was going to ask,
what does even the process
to become a judge?
Because I don't even know what that is.
Well,
depends on the athletic commission.
Okay.
I mean the,
the,
the local athletic commissions,
there's a lot of local athletic commissions where they do a better job then the
bigger athletic commissions really because the people that are involved are
dedicated,
mixed martial artists in Boston.
I know Joe Esposito was a part of the,
the commission and Joe Esposito was with my first karate instructor.
I mean,
he's the guy who was a lifelong martial artist,
so he is a very credible source of martial arts knowledge.
He's been involved as whole life.
Whereas you've got people in Nevada that came from boxing,
they were boxing judges,
and then someone said,
uh,
you know,
we need judges for MMA.
You know,
we'll just take,
take these boxing people and you know,
we'll use them to judge MMA fights and it's fucking crazy.
It's really crazy.
Well,
you know,
you've got people that don't understand how much a leg kick hurts and they don't
think that that's anything.
You know,
you've got people that they have no idea what's going on when you're watching in
fighting up against the cage,
if have no idea,
you know,
who's getting the better of those exchanges?
They just don't know.
They just see bodies moving,
you know,
and they just,
they don't see guys reversing positions back and forth and they really don't
understand what's happening.
It's a,
it's a real shame because the sport is growing in such,
it's such a huge way.
I mean it's,
it's exploding all over the world and leaps and bounds,
but then you're hampered by these bad judge calls,
you know?
Yeah.
It's terrible.
I know that it's robbed.
A lot of people have of not just,
um,
you know,
their,
their passion,
their hopes to win the fight,
but even that 50% one bonus,
that's disgusting.
So they're actually taking money out of people's pockets.
I should have,
should've won the fight.
If you decide and you have decided,
I guess to go and do this,
what's your timetable?
How much time are you going to spend training before you get in there?
I think,
I think I need at least,
um,
maybe before my first fight,
maybe around six months of,
actually once I'm in shape,
then training,
um,
at which I'll be getting in shape on training,
but,
but actually before I start taking some of the bigger,
tougher fights,
maybe it's,
maybe it's a year,
maybe it's longer than that.
It's not something that I'm going to do in the next month or two months or three
months.
It's,
it's gotta be a,
a process of really getting my lungs back,
get my core,
you know,
um,
tightened up.
So it prevents injuries,
getting the timing back of the striking,
you know,
and,
and timing back of you and the transitions on the ground,
that chain wrestling or,
or just flowing and grappling.
So you starting that process right now,
so you've already like tightened up your diet and started to train harder and
started that.
You just slowly ramping it up?
We got begun to one,
one thing that I'm,
I'm getting done before I really maybe start sparring before I start.
Um,
yeah,
before I start sparring,
things like that.
As I'm getting my knee checked,
checked,
I got an Mri done and so a doctor says it could be,
I mean,
Mri like scope can be three days down,
but I,
I might get some scope to either before or after my first fight back,
three days down.
What do you mean?
When someone's,
Oh,
even Loretta's husband was down for for only three days after getting his
meniscus scoped.
Three days.
Listen,
I've had my meniscus scoped a couple of times.
It's more than than,
than the,
that I know.
It can be two weeks,
three weeks,
six weeks.
You of be all that.
You want to make sure that you don't,
there's a lot of guys that have had knee operations and then got in too soon or
done more damage.
Brutal.
You're,
you're dealing with pain and inflammation and cutting away soft tissue.
It's not nearly as big a deal as like ligaments,
but it's so important with knee injuries,
especially to do the Rehab.
Just do,
do the full rehab,
you know,
you'll listen to,
I mean,
I'm sure if you get it done,
you'll get it done at a reputable place and you'll talk to a really good doctor.
I know it's the Denver Broncos and he doc talking to perfect.
Great Guy.
What's their prognosis as far as how long he first,
first Mri we sent his office,
um,
we think lost,
but I sent another one out and he's lost it.
Yeah,
well it got lost in the mail or something,
but we sent it in.
Uh,
the second one he's looking at though,
I went in for an exam,
he started moving my knee around.
He said it feels like there's something with my knee meniscus and whenever I
move it around it cracks a lot.
But I don't know that it's going to be something that keeps me out from,
from the first fight.
Maybe it's something I do right after.
Um,
but,
but I think it'd be good probably to get it done before getting them.
Yeah.
Get it done before so I can train.
Right.
That's what fuck cane up and the rematch with where the fight with very doom,
it's really nice because he blew his meniscus out earlier and then you know,
sort of rest and rehabbed and then tried to go back again without getting the
operation and then wound up having to get an operation in the same knee injury
that he had when the first fight with junior dos Santos.
Right.
For me,
before I want to actually hard spar.
I know it might sound kind of goofy to,
to some,
but I think there's,
there's truth to it.
Uh,
my,
my wife was a swimmer in high school and so getting into swimming,
something that's low impact but also that's going to be be great on my lungs.
Cardio,
you don't even notice that you're sweating,
you know.
Um,
so swimming,
we would do that at the Olympic training center.
We'd play underwater hockey and 12 foot deep.
We'd go down and just have teams have to score a goal in the swimming's.
Not goofy at all.
Went swimming and yoga is what I'm going to get into hard just to get me back my
body back in shape in a way that,
that my core starts to catch up and develop before I go in there and get put in
these funky position sparring or picking a guy up.
And that's been one of my problems.
And sometimes I'm slamming a guy or something and that's when I get hurt cause
it came back from an it back injury and then I slam and then I rehurt that I can
and I should have,
should rehabbed it better,
should have,
uh,
should have taken the time to really build my core backup.
And I'm so,
so that's going to be not my focus on be doing everything else,
but,
but that's going to be a priority of mine at the beginning is swimming and yoga.
Well listen dude,
we're behind you 100% and a your website.
Let's put it out there one more time.
Fight for the fight for the forgotten.org.com.
Dot Com.
Yeah.
And then,
and then water for.org so water four.org fight for the forgotten.com and there's
a donate button on there.
So please,
uh,
whatever you can do folks,
donate.
This is a beautiful cause.
I think what you're doing is awesome.
It's so inspirational and a,
you're just an awesome guy,
man.
Just happy to give you a platform to let people know what you're doing.
I can't thank you enough for,
for what you've done for,
for even,
I mean,
I know you don't want even when he,
even when perhaps,
but whenever you did the bitcoin and then whatever came in,
you matched it.
I mean that,
that funded a well plus plus more fun.
Some more wells baby do it.
I'd be more than happy.
Awesome man.
Thank you sir.
Awesome guy.
Thank you brother.
Thank you.
Just in the Viking on Twitter,
a Holler,
Adam,
go tweet them and go to the website and,
and donate whatever you can find.
This is a real legit,
awesome humanitarian cause and you're an awesome guy.
Thank you,
Justin.
Thank you so much.
All right,
fuckers.
We'll be back in a little bit with,
uh,
Eddie Wong a,
he's got a new CBS Sitcom and uh,
we'll be right back with him at three o'clock,
which is about 25 minutes to,
okay.